from the time it first appeared SCP ubu
has brought nothing but endless pain and
destruction without even the promise of
death as a release it dug holes in the
ground and buried millions of people
alive it threw cargo ships out of the
Earth's gravitational pole throwing them
so hard that several of them landed on
the moon it drove humans to abandoned
Society take to floating cities of
people drugged into a permanent sleep
the SCP Foundation could not stop it one
Furious Immortal researcher fueled by
rage and pain could not stop it but
still there is a home for Humanity in
the form of a child and a Frog puppet
one of the most fascinating and Powerful
groups of Interest known to the SCP
Foundation is the three moons initiative
what exactly is the three moons
initiative in short they are an
extradimensional human organization
based in corbon an afterlife Dimension
also known as SCP 29 9 22- C the
initiative was first founded
approximately 14,000 years ago with the
express purpose of establishing human
colonies in the afterlife the initiative
judges the sins of deceased humans and
selects their Associated punishments and
rewards via 2/3 majority vote of the
ption committee the humanity defense
Corp is the initiative's military branch
which acts as a multi-dimensional
security Force protecting the human race
from harm this Branch keeps a close eye
on Earth carrying out covert operations
in its Defense Initiative Personnel
always act in what they believe to be
Humanity's best interest but they are
not a perfect organization like any
group they have been guilty of poor
communication overreach and struggles
with internal bureaucracy in spite of
these flaws the SCP Foundation and the
three moons initiative have established
peace and cooperation via the Treaty of
KAG naaza three moons initiative
personnel tamino and metap
were strolling through the landscape of
Corvin on an ordinary Patrol walking
Beneath the Sea Green sky and black
clouds when suddenly a new person
manifested in the area they must have
been recently deceased he introduced
himself to the two officers as Aaron
gualtieri of the SCP Foundation they
welcomed him to the afterlife and
ushered him to a proper screening area
as he underwent the usual intake process
gualtieri seemed incredibly distressed
about something other than his recent
death they asked the man to explain what
troubled him and he told them quite the
story on May 12th
2588 Humanity was going to meet a
destructive force it would be entirely
unprepared to combat
scpu an enormous hairless White Beast
with no facial features except a mouth
and an insatiable appetite for violence
which would manifest in Greenland where
it would cause an endof death scenario
and beat Humanity's Collective Spirit
into the ground it would hunt endlessly
across the globe turning every city to
rubble and destroying the ground until
the Earth's surface was mostly ocean and
garbage it would destroy SCP 682 once
thought to be a threat without equal a
former SCP Foundation 05 council member
Dr moud traveling back in time to try
and stop this tragedy and to warn thep
Foundation about it but all of his
attempts to defeat the Beast had been
unsuccessful the foundation had not
allocated him the resources he had asked
for and had not partnered with him as he
had hoped he had attempted to take
matters into his own hands creating
human replicants of himself and taking
over the world again and again in hopes
of creating a strong enough Army to
defeat the Beast he had a personal
Vendetta against the monster after it
had tortured him with a twisted
approximation of bath time using his own
wife as a scrub brush he had Grand plans
for the Revenge he would enact once the
Beast could be contained but no matter
what he did no matter how much
collateral damage it wasn't enough
nothing was ever enough the three Moon's
Personnel were horrified to hear about
this senseless tragedy but one aspect of
gualtieri's account stuck out to them
his description of the vile Beast that
was SCP ubu sounded incredibly familiar
the more they thought about his story
The more familiar it sounded soon enough
tamino and matapang realized exactly
what it was a creature native to Corbin
that had somehow made its way to Earth
in the meantime they provided as much
support to the Fallen Foundation
employee as they could helping him to
acclimate to his new home in the
afterlife he was given a promotion and
welcomed into the ranks of their
Foundation continuance program so he
could continue the research he was so
passionate about even after death now
that the three moons knew what this
threat was they also knew how to stop it
and with the fate of humanity hanging in
the balance they needed to act fast
tamino and matapang were assigned to the
task with the help of an instance of SCP
5298 SCP 5298 is a type of three moons
initiative remote controlled military
drone but this isn't any ordinary drone
it has the appearance of a child between
the ages of 5 and 13 years old and
living under an individual assumed
identity they are always assigned a man
and a woman to act as the instances
parents in this case the parents were
tamino and Matt tapping SCP 5298 may
look harmless but they are extremely
powerful and their combat capabilities
include machine guns hidden in their
forearms finger-mounted electroshock
weapons hidden in their fingernails and
neurotoxin injecting barbs hidden in
their teeth their innocent appearance
only serves to mask their potential as a
deadly threat so with the team selected
and prepared for their mission it was
time to take a trip to the Greenland
Tundra tamino and matapang dawned hazmat
suits standing behind an arched metallic
barrier for their safety on the other
side of the barrier their particular
instance of SCP 5298 past the barrier
clad in white ceremonial robes that
would be much too cold for the weather
if the child wearing them was actually
humanid in the child's hand it carried
an oak Rod covered in ritualistic
carvings one by one tamino and matang
checked the various equipment the camera
was set the blast Shield was Secure the
kill vehicle contained in mat tap pang's
duffel bag was Secure the executive
drone was in route and the celbrate
Drone was in place though it was briefly
on autopilot which caused it to talk
back to tamino before its function was
overridden all at once the executive
drone arrived with the sound of a small
explosion it resembled a blue an orange
puppet similar in appearance to Kermit
the Frog and introduced itself with a
cheerful GRE reading H KY frog here
ready to dispense Swift and brutal
justice but taing rolled her eyes at the
side of the thing offering to deliver
the kill vehicle herself but with
everyone in place it was time to begin
the operation and they would be using
the Frog whether she liked it or not she
unzipped the duffel b as the Frog's
fingers were too thin to operate the
zipper and tamino ordered the celebrant
to commence with the next phase of the
operation the SCP 5298 instant sang A
Hymn in an unknown language for 24
seconds followed by a large explosion
and a burst of pale green light SCP 5298
exploded at this point and the barrier
buckled matapang opened her laptop
checking it for signs of Lambda waves
thankfully they were absent meaning that
the end of death scenario had been
avoided with that out of the way it was
time for the next phase the Frog drone
exited the barrier holding the kill
vehicle in its hand The Kill vehicle was
an unassuming sight a pointed wooden
stick approximately 1 m in length
engraved with the word cleansing several
hundred times there in a crater not too
far away was SCP ubu it had manifested
in a prone position but slowly began to
stand up straight giggling wickedly it
was searching for its favorite victim
the one it had been doing battle with
for Millennia it called out to Dr mcod
in its own peculiar way way looking
around for any sight of him but he
wasn't there instead there was an orange
and green frog tapping ubu on the
shoulder it spun around with a surprised
snarl Furious that its usual play thing
was nowhere to be found before ubu could
do anything or Babble another word the
Frog stabbed ubu in the stomach with the
pointed stick ubu responded not with a
roar but with a curious amused sound
suddenly it collapsed falling backward
as soon as it body hit the ground it
crumbled dissolving into a pile of white
powder not snow as it might have first
appeared but salt the target had been
officially successfully neutralized ubu
was gone for good shortly after this
successful operation the 05 Council
received an email from the three moons
initiative it read as follows foundation
in case you were not aware a researcher
of yours one Aaron gualtieri has
recently passed pass away upon his
arrival to Corbin and subsequent
retrieval by three Moon screening agents
Mr gualtieri informed us that your
iteration of Earth was due for a bit of
trouble with a certain creature that is
familiar to our world SCP ubu is rather
was a pantr or gargantuan venes ferox in
Latin a common nuisance in the canyon
south of outer scalli though I would not
doubt it destructive potential in a
world free of its natural enemies this
specimen in particular was unusually
small and weak for its species no doubt
it was the Run of its litter it's not
unheard of for a pentag gruu to access
one of many jump points in the Forbidden
prefectures to cause Mischief in other
dimensions and it's likely that this one
had secured second Prince naso's favor
in one way or another in order to anoint
its living presence with both the right
of world ceiling and the Eternal hunt
but should this happen again with
separate pagr remember this the
indigenous tribes of outer scavi hate
pantr for obvious reasons a common right
of passage for boys who reach the age of
13 is to leave the village not to return
until they've bagged a pentag GRU this
is how they pull it off this is how we
pulled it off and moving forward this is
how you should pull it off grab a length
of wood and sharpen it to a point carve
the word cleansing in any language into
it for a minimum of 200 times there is
no maximum but let's be honest doing it
more than 200 times isn't going to make
the pentag gru any de anywhere that
there's free space for carving left on
the stick engrave the following phrase
just as it's written here n Fu jalakara
stab it anywhere into the pentag guru's
body and there you have it as for Mr
gualtieri do not worry about him he has
been amply rewarded and offered a
position on the foundation continuance
program on Luna major I would suggest
naming something after him on your side
you owe him dearly you are watched you
are protected you are loved though the
instructions for dealing with future
pental infestations were helpful even
comforting there was a troubling element
to this letter as well
scpu the entity that had been decimating
the Earth and tortured all of its
inhabitants was the runt of its litter
if it had been able to accomplish so
much horror what could a stronger member
of its species accomplish accomplish
hopefully the world would never have to
find out but not everyone was relieved
to receive notice from the three moons
initiative upon receipt of the notice
from the three moons initiative Dr Macau
began to repeat one single word again
and again no all at once his plan for
vengeance was ripped away from him his
hope for seeing some sort of Justice
Done against SCP ubu gone in an instant
the thousands and thousands and
thousands of years the violence the
death the human replicants of him self
he made over and over through any means
necessary it had all been in service of
this greater purpose now what was it all
for overcome with despair he sealed the
bulkhead of the shipping container he
had made his home all the replicants of
himself he had made over the years
suddenly expiring after over a month of
continuous screaming he booted up his
old computer to type out one closing SC
SCP file on ubu his thoughts were
disjointed the combination of Despair
and and denial he acknowledged that his
plan had almost certainly failed the
plan put in motion just under 10 million
years ago but perhaps there was still a
chance he could find closure perhaps he
could do it all he would need to do was
keep screaming louder and louder until
one day a higher power took pity on him
and sent him an SCP ubu das2 and he
could be the one to kill and punish it
no that wasn't a good enough plan
instead he would rely on his willpower
he would focus his energy via eons of
screaming and manifest SCP ub-2 through
sheer force of will then it would be a
good day then he would win then he
wouldn't have to scream anymore until
that day he would carry boundless hatred
with nowhere to put it no joy only
struggle without killing torture without
satisfaction conflict without resolution
there was no one left for maau to hate
but himself the laboratory was cold he
wished someone was there to cover him
with a blanket but no one was so instead
he searched for a distraction he
remembered then that the computer
contained a morale boosting video game
one that had attempted to get him to
play it in the past he had never wanted
to play it before but now maybe it was
just what he needed he saved his file
and the familiar prompt popped up on
screen it's text a garish cheerful pink
hey user file Untitled one.txt display
evidence of severe down in the dumps
stude Prometheus Labs cares about your
mental health why not take a break and
play a video game just type runor swinky
to join the hunt for Mr swinky after all
swinky Len needs you to catch that
sneaky Mr swinky before he misses
princess panky's birthday party with a
resign saigh the being that had once
been an ordinary human man named Dr
maccau typed run _ swinky into the
console why not after all he's been
through he might as well give it a shot
additional text scrolled across the
console please enter the 16-digit code
found on the back of the provided swink
kit to prove that this is a legitimate
copy of the hunt for Mr swinky there was
no kit that he could find nothing
anywhere in the shipping container if
there had ever been one here it was
likely lost a millennia ago again he
screamed once more a sound that that has
persisted to this day maybe one day the
universe will bring Dr macod a new
outlet for his endless rage but for now
he has nothing left to do but scream
until his voice gives out mourning the
loss of an enemy the rest of the world
has forgotten the suffering he had felt
belonged to another timeline one that
would never come to pass leaving maow
without a place in this one so all that
was left to do was scream boom on May
12th 2588 the town of Kangas Greenland
was destroyed by a devastating 4 kiloton
explosion accompanied by a massive
electromagnetic pulse the few survivors
that made it through the incident alive
described seeing a pale green light in
the area at the time of the explosion
shortly after an omka class scenario or
endof death scenario began in which all
multicellular life on Earth began to
experience a regenerative effect regard
regardless of injury or illness in other
words nobody could die anymore this
resulted in intense worldwide panic in
the face of the inexplicable occurrence
as the Panic mounted the 05 Council of
the FCP Foundation held an emergency
meeting in order to address the
possibilities at hand meanwhile
civilians began reporting sightings of a
gigantic pale white humanoid monster
rampaging through their cities and
communities wrecking havoc and violently
attacking anyone and anything thing in
its path as the situation progressed and
worsened and the reality of the end of
death scenario began to set in the SCP
Foundation made the difficult decision
to lift its veil of secrecy and reveal
itself to the world
05-18 further instructions 5 days after
the world learned the truth of the SCP
Foundation the pale monster arrived in
St John's New Finland where it was met
by mobile task force new7 hammerdown for
what they hoped would be a quick fight
and neutralization instead 2 years of
devastating bloody combat ensued by July
4th 2590 90% of the Task Force personnel
had been killed and regenerated an
average of five times at this point MTF
news7 abandoned the city of St John
citing anomalously poor working
conditions after being held in place for
2 years the monster was able to break
through the defensive line and continue
its Rampage on October 10th 2590 the SCP
Foundation and the global occult
Coalition came together in an act of
unprecedented cooperation to found
project Beluga dedicated to the goal of
neutralizing the monster designated SCP
ubu and stopping its reign of terror but
project Beluga was unable to neutralize
the entity before it reached Columbus
Ohio on December 29th 2590 once it
arrived in the city SCP ubu began
dedicating its time to a gruesome
personal project first it dug a 2 km
deep hole in the city's Center next it
gathered a total of 2.9 Million
civilians throwing them into the hole
after the hole was full The Entity
leaped into the upper Stratosphere over
and over again stomping into the hole
each time when the people inside were
pulverized The Entity destroyed a large
Fountain which it used as a cup and
drank the resulting juices from the hole
this entire process took roughly 1 year
and when it was finished the entity
appeared to grow bored with Columbus and
moved to Lake Erie upon reaching Lake
Erie SCP ubu trudged out into the water
and began assaulting the cargo ship
stock there it began lifting ships up
and throwing them out of the water some
flying high enough to exit Earth's
gravitational pole altogether two of the
ships were later spotted on the surface
of the Moon this chaos and destruction
continued for years and years until June
10th
2670 when SCP ubu was contained at SCP
Foundation site 59 however this
containment only lasted for 2 minutes at
which point The Entity escaped and made
its way to New York City where it was
found howling and attempted to defile
the Statue of Liberty several countries
used their nuclear arsenals to attack
SCP ubu over the course of its Rampage
until this connectic agreement was
signed on February 10th
2674 cementing an agreement between NATO
Powers the Russian Federation the
People's Republic of China and the
global occult Coalition all signatories
agreed that due to concerns around the
environment any additional nuclear
strikes against the entity would be
prohibited after the signing was
finished SCP ubu crashed the ceremony
grabbing several lengths of rebar and 15
foreign dignitaries which it used to
construct itself a bead necklace the
next notable incident occurred when SCP
ubu showed up at site 19 interrupting a
round of testing with SCP AF a woman
capable of turning matter into stone by
speaking to it SCP ubu broke through the
ceiling crushing AFF beneath its weight
SCP 682 which was also present
approached the entity curiously and SCP
ubu responded by angrily defecating and
shouting at SCP 682 in gibberish SCP 682
seemed to understand this vocalist
ization and attacked SCP ubu demanding
that it take back the insult at this
point SCP ubu slapped 6 82's cheek
causing 682 to let out a horrific Scream
the slap left behind a glowing green
Mark which spread over the entity of
682s body before breaking the bonds of
its cells all at once dissolving the
reptile into a pool of toxic fluid SC
SCP ubu then spent 5 minutes bathing in
this fluid while giggling after
finishing its bath devouring the the
reconstituted SCP and screaming into the
microphone for 20 minutes SCP ubu broke
into armed containment area 179 and
swallowed SCP 2317 hole on March 5th
2686 SCP ubu conducted an assault on
Thal class SCP 2000 rendering it
neutralized again years of Hell passed
as project Beluga struggled to come up
with new methods that had not already
been exhausted meanwhile civilians did
their their best to find ways to cope
with the state of the world on March
25th 2750 former film star Nash deg grut
published the zon Manifesto A book based
around a simple principle life on Earth
was no longer worth living consciously
and the only way formed was to enter an
eternal coma through the combination of
chemicals and guided meditation this
kickstarted the social movement the
international zon on June 24th 2790
project Beluga forces managed to drive
SC pu U into the Bay of Bengal where
remained for 3 years causing very little
trouble aside from underwater seismic
events meanwhile the international Zone
continued to grow and one massive
adherence known as cutopia reached its
goal of 5 million residents on June 10th
2793 SCP ubu flung SCP 3000 out of the
ocean leaving it beached on the soil of
India several cities were destroyed in
this process The Entity then spent a
week pointing and laughing at The
Beached sea monster before grabbing it
by the tip of its tail and beginning to
drag it across Asia SCP ubu continued
carving a path through Asia the
wriggling SCP 3000 in tow until it
reached the bearing straight then it
began to cross the straight into Alaska
returning to North American territory
once more but it didn't stop there
instead advancing toward South America
until it and SCP 3000 arrived on the
eastern coast of Brazil on August 29th
2793 there it dragged its unfortunate
charge back into the ocean once more
disappearing from sight on August 30th
2793 SCP 169 or the Leviathan emerged
from the depths of the ocean there are
some reports that SCP 3000 had been tied
around its neck but these have not been
confirmed the Leviathan and SCP ubu then
entered into a lengthy battle which
carried on for several hundred years
after so much time had passed pass that
Witnesses could scarcely remember a time
when it wasn't happening the fight
between SCP ubu and SCP 169 came to a
halt much as it had with SCP 682 SCP ubu
slapped SCP 169 across the face with
such force that its cell bonds dissolved
and it melted into a puddle of fluid
which was lost beneath the ocean waves
SCP 169 was reclassified neutralized
December 11th 3020 marked the start of a
10-year period of inactivity for SCP ubu
ordinarily one would expect this to come
with a sense of relief however even in
spite of the global immortality the
collateral damage from SCP ubu's
centuries of Carnage had rendered the
surface of the Earth uninhabitable with
all land now underwater the remains of
human civilization persist on a single
archipelago of floating cities
constructed from ships and debris
meanwhile the international zon movement
has persisted gaining more and more
traction and popularity as conscious
life became less and less bearable an
enormous floating zon pile consisting of
international zon followers using
anomalous methods to achieve the perfect
zon began to form eventually this pile
earned the nickname new zland by May
28th 3028 the archipelago was abandoned
and the 140 remaining conscious humans
retreated to the SCP foundation's scps
naith there they lived in relative
safety for several months until SCP ubu
was spotted in the water off the port B
of the naysmith on January 14th 3030 it
emitted several sounds that Witnesses
described as mocking before swimming off
towards new zlin in response to this
reappearance after 10 years of
inactivity the 05 Council called an
emergency meeting the transcript for
this meeting reads as follows we haven't
exhausted all our anomolous options for
neutralizing ubu where's the corn CR
we've been over sorence so the Ki in
this mess is only going to it is
anchored 57 clicks due Southeast for why
the hell did you tell him that well
friends it seems the Omega K has had us
up in about so long that our
personalities have run out of fuel we
were given from birth in all likelihood
we'd see better professionalism and
teamwork in new zland as a matter of
fact that's a good segue into what I was
about to propose and frankly I hope you
find the nicest cleanest spots in the
mass grave where are you going that
fence which way is southeast at this
point 05-11 left the room presumably to
track down the corn CR leaving the
remains of the 05 Council there and
leaving the remains of project Beluga
with the question of how to handle SCP
ubu according to its official SCP
Foundation file SCP ubu is an extremely
violent and hostile humanoid entity of
Unknown Origin which appeared in
Greenland on May 12th 2588 it displays
anomalous physical strength in speed as
well as reality bending capabilities and
the emission of regenerative Lambda
waves linked to the ongoing end of death
scenario the appearance of SCP ubu and
the start of the endof death scenario
coincided with several additional
phenomenon there was a mass loss of
function for all the objects operated by
the three moons initiative the three
moons initiative was an extradimensional
human organization based in SCP
2922 C or the afterlife known as
corbenic this organization was founded
14,000 years ago with the purpose of
establishing a human colony in the
afterlife and has long maintained a
peace treaty with the SCP Foundation SCP
2922 a method of communication that
allowed a human mind to make calls to
any pre-established phone number ceased
all functions next the extradimensional
space known as the wanderer's library a
magical Archive of all the knowledge
from all known worlds and every book
that has ever been written will be
written and several that have not and
will not exist was severed from Earth
when the SCP Foundation pressed the
Serpent's hand for answers a
representative answered that
irreconcilable security concerns
regarding Earth had come up and forced
them to make this decision a
representative of Marshall Carter and
dark limited somehow gained access to
the personal contact information of the
05 council's members and used this
information to reach out to them with a
business offer the company is ordinarily
on unfriendly terms with the SCP
Foundation
due to their conflicting interests
namely Marshall Carter and dark's
interests in acquiring and selling
anomalous items entities and experiences
to the highest bidder however in this
case the company's representative
approached 05 council members with a
mixture of politeness and Desperation
begging the SCP Foundation to purchase
large amounts of the company's stock the
forest known as SCP 4000 lost all of its
anomalous properties all at once
investigation revealed only a small
parchment note in the area's entryway
which read good luck one of the most
perplexing and disconcerting phenomenon
that occurred concurrently with SCP
ubu's first appearance was what happened
to SCP 3 2008 the infinite Ikea though
this sort of thing should have been
impossible the infinite Ikea was
anomalously purchased by some unknown
entity the Ikea branding was stricken
from the building and it was converted
into an emergency shelter all of these
occurrences combined to serve as a
warning some something big is coming and
indeed it was
scpu it appears to be impervious to most
forms of damage including blunt force
trauma heavy caliber machine gun fire
temperatures up to 1600° Kelvin
artillery fire and Direct Energy
discharge from other anomalies it did
express some discomfort when exposed to
severe simultaneous direct nuclear
strikes but it was not affected beyond
that the only recorded instance of
lasting damage to scpu ubu was on August
14th 2784 in which the entity bit its
left thumb seemingly for no reason other
than curiosity after biting its thumb
The Entity screen for 7 days straight
then entered into a month-long crying
fit 30 years and 14 days later the thumb
had completely healed SCP ubu stands at
a height of 4.3 m one exact measure of
its weight is unknown attempts at
measurement during its brief time in
containment showed that its weight is at
least 15,000 399 kg its exact anatomical
composition is unknown but a superficial
examination of the entity indicates that
its body shape resembles that of a large
androgenous humanoid covered in hairless
white skin similar in texture to that of
a dolphin or small whale The Entity has
no eyes ears or nostrils but seems to
still possess the ability to see hear
and smell its only visible sensory organ
aside from its skin is its5 M wide mouth
humanoid in nature with a prehensile
tongue of unknown length on its lower
body it has no apparent features aside
from a coloa that it uses to dispose of
waste SCP ubu is prone to vocalizations
mainly screaming laughing and babbling
but it does not appear to understand
speech in any known language nor does it
seem to be attempting to communicate
with anyone it encounters its primary
interest appears to be destruction and
causing as much of it as possible it
will attack anything that can get its
hands on but seems to show a particular
preference for attacking and consuming
human beings in large populous areas
such as cities its demeanor is both
sadistic and childlike and it has been
seen playing with its victims for hours
before moving on to a new Target due to
its regenerative effect present in SCP
ubu's vicinity it is incapable of
causing permanent damage to any living
thing and seems to have no greater
motivation Beyond causing fear and pain
SCP ubu is classified as Tiamat meaning
that it cannot be reasonably contained
at this time with the resources that the
foundation has therefore the focus has
shifted from containment to
neutralization which is ongoing via
project Beluga any and all non-critical
resources will be funneled into project
Beluga as neutralization of SCP ubu is a
top priority additional information on
neutralization efforts is restricted and
may only be accessed by members of
project Beluga but in the end it won't
project Beluga that defeats this
monstrous creature it'll be the staunch
efforts of one extremely dedicated
researcher on May 12th 2588 The Entity
known as SCP ubu manifested in Kangas
Greenland like something out of the most
nightmarish Kaiju movie never made soon
after there was no more death but the
world was filled with such chaos and
despair that Humanity longed for that
Eternal release from its enormous
stomping feet to its cloa to its face
featureless save for a gaping grinning
devouring mouth The Entity was pure
malice with all the time in the world
ubu decimated the planet breaking the
spirit of mankind and raising every city
to the ground in the earlier days of
ubu's invasion when there was still dry
land and people still wanted to talk to
each other rather than joining floating
islands of Eternal chemically induced
Slumber they would commiserate about the
shared misery of the state of things oh
UVU I hasn't spoken to me ever since
that monster shoved my whole body down
her throat someone would say another
would pipe up trying to one up the first
man in sort of a trauma Olympics didn't
you see me in the news ubu carried me
around for a week snacking on me every
now and then like I was his own personal
Turkey Leg it was hell but honestly part
of me felt a little bummed out when he
threw me away yet another person would
chime in like veterans swapping War
Stories over a drink at the bar ubu made
me eat a pair of my pants whole thing
zipper for and all then he decided he
thought that was funny made me eat pair
after pair after pair of them rinse and
repeat by the time he got bored I'd
eaten probably around 20 paars and sort
of got a taste for them after that
everyone on the planet had good reason
to despise SCP uu but no one held more
hate in his heart for the pale Wicked
creature than Dr Lawrence mikal before
the world was turned upside down
sometimes literally Dr moud was a member
of the mysterious 05 council at the CP
Foundation to be specific he was
05-11 but that prestigious position at
the foundation couldn't protect him or
his loved ones from the wrath of ubu
when Dr moud was off duty ubu attacked
him and his wife first it impaled his
wife on a broom handle next it threw Dr
moud into an open pool of sewage in the
street then it bathed him in the filthy
water using his screaming wife as a
scrubbing brush all the while whistling
a horrible little bathtub song centuries
after that awful experience as Dr moud
watched most of his colleagues give up
and choose the closest thing to death in
this broken world he became even more
determined to do something about it on
January 14th 3030 Dr moud abandoned the
scps naith and his fellow 05 council
members in search of the scps Corn CR an
abandoned craft to the southeast it
wasn't an easy Journey rowing all the
way there in a Lifeboat never knowing
when the Great White Beast would emerge
from the water and choose him as its
next unfortunate play thing he could see
the scps corn cek still floating there
untouched but before he could row any
closer something collided with the
Lifeboat From Below snapping it in half
Dr macau's stomach dropped at the sight
of pale flesh but it was soon replaced
with relief when he saw that the thing
that had broken his lifebo was not in
fact ubu it was an injured narwhal
behaving erratically due to its wounds
the culprit was almost certainly ubu it
wasn't content to just torment humans
but instead must have been targeting any
life form that could feel pain and fear
in his own words Dr moud had put it at
least a mass extinction wouldn't have
made it that personal after the lifebo
broke apart moud swam to the conre
exhaustion and cold straining his
muscles it took him 2 hours to reach the
abandoned cargo barge and containment
site but eventually he managed to climb
up over the side and get on board there
was one very special thing about the
corn crate the thing that made it worth
crossing the ocean in a fragile little
Lifeboat to find every anomaly that made
the gamed list the list of anomalies
considered too dangerous to abandon even
in an apocalyptic scenario was contained
on the corn crake if there was anything
left that the foundation or anyone else
hadn't tried to use to defeat ubu it
would be on that ship after taking a
little while to recover Dr moud embarked
on an initial exploration of The Craft
all the staff were gone as he had
expected thankfully he still had his 05
ID card and it still worked like a charm
unlocking all of the automated security
systems on board a lot of what he found
was in Ruins but some things had
survived he found 10 hominid replicators
from SCP 2000 in perfect working order
there was a cage containing the remains
of SCP 2845 the deer though ubu had done
significant damage to it SCP 319 a
curious device was there contained in
the space locked vacuum chamber this one
was notable for its potential ability to
destroy the universe he found a couple
of safe class anomalies such as SCP yez
crowd control for the Practical Optimist
and SCP FNA the portable warehouse the
latter of the two was a portable door
frame to a pocket Dimension he also
stumbled upon SCP 001 Last Ride of the
day an old Prometheus lab's prototype of
a time machine and possibly most
importantly he found SCP
076 the coffin was open but Abel didn't
attack Dr maoud he wasn't consumed with
murderous rage and blood lust the way he
always was before instead he was just
sitting on the edge of the ship silently
staring at the sea when he spotted moud
he gave him a small wave and did nothing
else the centuries of a world without
death a world without killing without
victory in battle had taken its toll on
him for possibly the first time in his
eternal life Abel was depressed 9 days
after he first inspected the Corn Creek
mik began to formulate a plan he loaded
all the hominid receptors into SCP FNA
using a thankfully still working
forklift next he was able to unseal the
sealed portion of SCP 001 Last Ride of
the day and get his hands on the details
of the anomaly it read SCP 001 is
capable of temporally relocating to its
relative position 15,000 years prior to
activation this temporal displacement is
Divergent Paradox Irrelevant in other
words a separate timeline is created as
a landing point for example if an
occupant from timeline X were to murder
their parents in utero in Timeline y the
Y iteration of the occupant would no
longer exist but the occupant themselves
being from X would be unharmed when in a
fully active State SCP 1 deploys a 5 m
High telescopic antenna that functions
as a coloo wave energy sink essentially
Colo waves could only be produced as a
byproduct of the universe suddenly being
exterminated and ZK class reality
failures produced the most Colo waves in
one of these scenarios SC SCP 001 would
be able to use these waves to go back in
time 15,000 years effectively resetting
reality to a point far before the
catastrophe happened this information
allowed him to put his plan together to
resurrect project Beluga step one plant
explosive charges around SCP 39 step two
hide anything potentially useful against
SCP ubu inside of SCP FNA step three get
into the cockpit with SCP FNA and toe
step four raise the Colo sink and step
five blow the whole thing up 3 days
later it was time to put the plan into
motion Dr moud placed the charges around
SCP 39's vacuum chamber there was enough
in place to implode the walls of the
vacuum chamber he closed the bulkhead
and began deploying the Colo sink 10%
25% 30% suddenly he could hear a loud
crashing sound the ship began to tilt oh
no he could hear the distant sound of
menacing Giggles the sync reached 45 57
but as ubu grew closer he quickly
overrode the system to lower the sink
45% 30% 25% % 10% ubu grew closer and
closer and as it approached it began to
whistle the tune it once used when it
bathed moud and his wife in the sewer
ubu began to pound against the blast
door becoming increasingly frustrated as
it struggled to break through suddenly
another voice cut through the air an
unexpected one SCP 076 Abel called out
to maod encouraging him to carry on
while Abel held the Beast back as Abel
and yubu engaged in an epic battle maau
suddenly remembered something there was
an Express deployment module for the
Colo syn with no time to waste he
activated it all at once he hit the
Detonator and then the year was
11,970 and the date was February 14th
13,960 years later the SCP Foundation
discovered something beneath a mound of
Earth and snow near the northern border
of Lapland Finland it was a shipping
container with a reinforced exterior the
interior of which which could only be
accessed through a fortified bulkhead on
one side the words SCP 001 were written
on the side in black paint in spite of
this the object was given the
designation SC SCP 848 a narrow winding
tunnel through the mound of Earth and
snow was discovered leading from the
door to the outside world the tunnel had
significant wear clearly having been
used as a flip path by someone but who
well on April 12th 1993 the foundation
got their answer SCP 80 48's bulkhead
opened and a man stepped out snapping
his fingers and promptly sealing the
door behind him he was designated pole
848 he was a 32-year-old man of French
Canadian descent answering to the name
of Dr Lawrence moud he made a series of
claims that the foundation found dubious
but noted it in the official file for
SCP 8848 just the same these included
but were not limited to SCP 848 is a
time machine he held the office of 05-11
in in the year 3030 from an alternate
timeline said timeline experienced a
modified Omega K class endof death
scenario that coincided with the
invasion of a Tiamat class anomaly known
as SCP ubu SCP ubu was an extremely
dangerous and sadistic entity who was
capable of among other things
neutralizing SCP 169 and SCP 682 his
timelines version of the foundation
launched project Beluga which resulted
in an impossible war with SC P ubu that
lasted 441 years Paul 848 deliberately
sabotaged SCP 319 to act as a power
source for SCP 8848 thus arriving in
Lapland in the year
11,970 BCE s SCP ubu will arrive in
Greenland on May 12th
2588 Paul 848 was able to extend his
lifespan by sharing his Consciousness
between a central computer with an SCP
8848 and several thousand bodies created
by his personal hominid replicators said
Consciousness sharing was achieved
through a book classified in the future
as SCP yez he wishes to assist the
foundation in the termination of SCP ubu
and has laid out a plan for its
termination as outlined in document 848
dzeta there were of course concerns
about the man's legitimacy but after
moud mentioned over4 specific terms and
data points known only to members of the
05 Council the foundation was forced to
take him at least a little bit seriously
a motion was filed requesting that poll
8048 be allowed to assist the foundation
with the termination of SCP ubu as per
document 848 Zeta 054 voted yay 057
abstained and the rest of the council
voted nay the motion failed to pass a
follow-up motion was filed in response
requesting that poll 848 be allowed to
assist the foundation with their own
strategy to respond to SCP ubu 0 5-1 0
5-4 057 and 05-10 abstained from voting
the rest voted nay the motion failed to
pass on April 14th 1995 Dr Isaiah
Henderson and pole 848 sat down for an
interview when asked to State his name
Dr maau also recited a mimetic
passphrase that when spoken by anyone
other than 05-11 of past or present
would cause them to burst into flames
the two men were at odds from the
beginning Dr Macau expressed dismay and
frustration that his proposal was
rejected meanwhile Dr Henderson
countered with the insistence that
macau's proposed plan was rejected for
posing an unnecessary risk to the
civilian public they debated for a
moment before Dr Henderson announced the
foundation's next plan of action Dr moud
was to be terminated the foundation
would proceed with its plans without him
at that point Dr Henderson terminated
mcow as ordered he didn't count on one
thing though moud was no longer an
ordinary man bound to one body he hopped
into the body of a guard then into the
body of 05- 4 to deliver a vital message
he had started this plan alone and was
ready to bring it to a close alone
project Beluga would continue with or
without the foundation's support Dr
Macau returned to the bulkhead climbing
back inside and sealing it behind him he
had hoped to have the foundation behind
him he had hoped they would be allies in
the fight against the greatest evil
mankind ever encountered but they
disappointed him he had waited thousands
of years only for the organiz ation he
devoted his life to to try and kill him
well he wasn't going to go down without
a fight this was bigger than the
foundation bigger than anyone and no
living person was as equipped to handle
ubu as he was so he resumed project
Beluga as a oneman operation he issued a
mission statement which read as follows
on May 12th 2588 The Entity known as SCP
ubu invaded and pillaged human
civilization for no other motivation
than cruelty and selfish gratification
shortly thereafter project Beluga was
founded as a joint effort between the
goblo Cod Coalition and the SCP
Foundation for the purposes of ubu's
Destruction ubu is not merely a threat
to human safety is an affront to every
positive and loving Concept in the human
consciousness rather than our lives he
seeks to destroy our quality of life to
sa his own sick desires think about it
the taste of ice cream playing with your
dog the way you out after your first
kiss that is ubu's sworn Enemy No fate
is too cool for him no hatred is strong
enough when project Beluga Charter was
signed 592 go officers and Foundation
staff were present at the ceremony our
troops numbered in the hundreds of
thousands I Dr Lin moud am the only
surviving member and always will be what
I lack in numbers is compensated
thousandfold by my weapons my mind my
replicated bodies and the ons of
experience the following record serves
one purpose alone that once justice has
been brought to ubu humans in The
Shining and golden ubu free future will
understand that one person can
accomplish through the power of hard
science and ra motion entwined in a
perfect and indestructible braid and
while we are at it you are very welcome
over the next several hundred years mow
worked to secure ownership of kusto
Greenland through a project Beluga
civilian front he evacuated the the
civilian population from the area then
spent a century constructing a super
weapon with 100 high yield nuclear
weapons heat amplification runes a
targeting Beacon for SCP dag and five
antimatter Gathering pods from SCP H&M
in place he was finally ready for ubu to
manifest again Dr Macau former member of
the SCP foundation's 05 Council had one
sworn enemy one being that he despised
more than any anything else in the
entire universe the being known as
scpu the monster that had eliminated
death and destroyed the world the
vengeful doctor was able to successfully
go back in time to the days before as CP
ubu first manifested desperate to
prevent the horrors he witnessed during
ubu's centuries long Rampage after the
SCP Foundation failed to help him with
his plan Dr moud spent thousands of
years reesta lishing project Beluga in
this new timeline the project secured
ownership of Kango Greenland evacuated
the civilian population and constructed
Beluga 1 in the epicenter of ubu's
manifestation point it was outfitted
with 100 high yield nuclear weapons heat
amplification runes copied from SCP NSF
a targeting Beacon for SCP dag and five
antimatter Gathering pods from SCP H&M
the Trap was set and it was time to wait
for SCP ubu to appear when it did and
the trap was sprung SCP ubu managed to
escape unharmed rampaging through the
world much like it did the first time
that attempt failed but it was not the
only one Dr Macau was not about to give
up now he restarted the cycle again
using replicates in order to gain a
greater amount of control over both the
SCP Foundation and the global cult
Coalition 25 years before SCP used U's
scheduled arrival Dr maau opened email
based Communications with SCP
2803a P Hudson gawk a giant tumorous
blob of Flesh in an abandoned anomalous
office building with the genius Mind of
a former CEO regarding the threat he
informed gawk that in 25 years time
something was going to destroy the
entire global economy particularly the
Consumer Electronics Market this
massively distressed as CP 2803 - A at
this point Dr Macau asked if the anomaly
might have a skill set that could help
prevent ubu from destroying the economy
and of course the rest of the world SCP
2803a as it turns out did indeed have a
strategy in mind one year before ubu's
arrival 2803 D attacked parasitized and
fused with SCP 169 the Leviathan this
Fusion resulted in a creature 1.5 times
the original size of SCP 169 with
several heads the resulting collateral
damage was catastrophic killing billions
of civilians when the creature came face
to face or faces with ubu it lasted
centuries before ubu made the killing
blow maau repeated the cycle again and
again and again and again in some Cycles
he tweaked his plans by the tiniest of
degrees other Cycles were dramatically
different from the ones that came before
4 during cycle 273 he increased the
aperture from the Beluga 94 project
teleporting the entire continent of
Greenland into another dimension after
ubu first appeared both Greenland and
ubu vanished on 512
2588 however only 5 minutes later a
second ubu materialization event
occurred the Rampage continued on from
there Dr Macau was becoming discouraged
and considered modifying his Central
Consciousness containment unit to to
forcibly redirect any negativity he felt
away from himself and his abilities and
toward ubu during cycle 530 maod
established site assembly in Cypress in
the year
10,485 BCE the Beluga X unit was
constructed over the course of 3,000
years there this feat was achieved via
the infiltration of the Church of the
broken God which was converted into the
false pretense Labor division of project
Beluga saric cult activity spread
through Europe as as a result but this
was an acceptable amount of collateral
damage What mattered most was the Beluga
x a heavily armed construct based around
the design of SCP 2406 the Colossus
replicate 5818 one of the many mcau
replicates was selected for the role of
majority Consciousness holder then 10
minutes after ubu manifested Beluga X
was deployed Beluga X confronted SCP ubu
and declared the intent to stop its
Invasion at the sound of macau's voice
ubu responded with the call sure it
promptly began to whistle the bathtime
song the same one it had whistled so
very very long ago while tormenting Dr
mcod somehow this ubu was the original
one from the very first timeline how did
it survive how long had it been
following Dr maau the refused to answer
any of these questions Beluga X charged
at ubu but slipped in a pile of the
Beast dung falling to the ground the
cycle was a failure and Dr moud was
filled with more dread and hopelessness
than ever in cycle 675 the moon's
gravitational pole was increased causing
it to collide with ubu during the
materialization event this Collision
succeeded and the Earth was completely
destroyed there was too much debris to
determine if ubu survived being hit by
the moon or not this was unacceptable to
Dr macow in the following cycle Dr macow
took a more human approach over the
course of 10 Millennia replicates
forcibly converted 90% of the human
population to an invented religion
called Spade of Triumph also known as
spis the primary mode of worship in spis
was the creation of as many Beluga 900
units as physically possible conflicts
between spis and the rest of the world
religions resulted in many wars and
spads had enslaved 5.9 billion people by
2500 CE by the time ubu manifested there
were still not enough Beluga 900 units
to make a difference cycle 677 was
identical to cycle 530 in every way
until the year 2500 CE at this point
Beluga x mark II was created and piloted
directly by the consciousness of Dr moud
it was first tested on 1225 2500 at
which time Dr maow destroyed half of
Asia over a period of 8 hours billions
were killed this cycle was not intended
to stop ubu it was a prime numbered
cycle and thus according to macau's own
personal rules was to be used for stress
relief in the form of Senseless
destruction during cycle 678 moud came
to a troubling conclusion he was running
out of resources hominid replicators
were broken Beyond repair leaving only
305 replicates where there should have
been Millions SCP 319 could not be
secured and there were no more stolen
SCP 2700 cores to make matters worse
there were not not enough resources to
gather additional working homonid
replicators from SCP 2000 he would have
to make contact with the SCP Foundation
again and the goal of project Beluga
would have to be modified from
termination to containment he drafted
containment procedures to be implemented
the moment the opportunity presented
itself these containment procedures were
unlike any penned by the foundation
before they were not simply a
containment method they were a
punishment they were a Vengeance to
ensure the internal Agony that Dr maau
believed SCP ubu empirically deserved
area ubu was constructed within site
Beluga metas spatial Mainframe area ubu
is a pocket Dimension where Dr moud is
God it consists of 1 square kilm of wide
open nothing Dr macau's will was capable
of causing the area to repeat at infinum
depending on where SCP ubu moved this
essentially meant that there was no
Escape no Edge only infinite emptiness
in Ma's words no one to run from him no
one to fight him no one to hurt there
would be no death in this space and it
would be equipped with an indestructible
floor Dr macau's plan Illustrated how
this Millennial long battle had taken a
toll on his own sanity by his plan ubu
would be kept in this uncaring Solitude
for as long as it would take for the
futility of his situation to set in his
laughter would become confusion his
confusion would become anger his anger
would become whimpering his whimpering
would become begging his begging would
become sobbing and his sobbing would
become wailing this process would
continue until ubu began to eventually
adjust to its surroundings once it began
to feel comfortable and began to
experience the smallest glimmer of hope
Macau would implement the next stage of
his containment procedure he would
summon a dark and Mountain High and
unspeakably strong version of himself
with fingers like gleaming scalpel he
planned to destroy ubu in countless ways
warping the monster squishing its body
and molding it like clay then it would
only get worse for the Beast as Dr
macau's plans for Revenge made him just
as horrific a monster as his enemy
according to macau's plans he would
clone ubu a companion a wife the first
real friend he has ever had and will
harden her heart and make her despise
him she will reject him cruy and
viciously she will curse the day she
ever met something so objectively
hideous as SCP ubu and if that doesn't
drive the point home enough she would
offer her heart to maow himself
effectively cuckolding his worst enemy
at this point Macau planned to destroy
the fabricated wife in front of ubu
these procedures were only the beginning
of the intake proceedings after that
maau would move on to one of 148 level
two sub routines while writing these
containment procedures Dr mcau smiled
for the first time in over 1 million
years in the description section of the
file he wrote only one thing reap what
you sow then it was time to try a new
cycle to begin a new in the year 2022
the SCP Foundation was planning a full
exploration attempt of an anomaly known
as SCP 001 D SCP 001 d a was a shipping
container the exterior of which was
reinforced with an unknown substance SCP
001 d-1 was a flat metallic device
serving as the container's cockpit SCP
001 a-2 were 57 identical humanoid
entities of indeterminant gender or
identity dressed in blue jumpsuits with
the words project Beluga emblazoned on
them all entities were found in and
around the cockpit they were all notably
hostile and would attempt to attack
investigators when the cockpit was
opened it revealed SCP 001 a-3 an extra
dimensional space that consisted mainly
of interior corridors for a fortified
storage area on September 1st 2022 the
speaker system of SCP 001's internal
console began to loudly broadcast a
concerning announcement first it began
with emergency emergency emergency
followed by the mimetic passphrase that
could only be spoken by a current or
former
05-11 without the subject immediately
bursting into flames the announcement
continued likelihood of ganam protocol
enactment if non-action is taken
approximately 100% XK SK ZK YK class
scenario all pending I am stranded on
the 50th basement level of SCP 001 a-3
there are possibly several children down
here with me this message will repeat
until my demands are met help me
emergency emergency emergency site
director nay Smith and the 05 Council
were both consulted on the matter and
researcher Aaron gutii was chosen to
meet with whoever was responsible for
the distress call he had recently been
exposed to a faf near class infohazard
and was scheduled for termination
sometime soon anyway so he decided to
use his dying hours productively he was
equipped with a hidden microphone and
sent to speak with the broadcaster while
Ty entered SCP 001 - a-3 descending to
level B15 he took 15 steps into the
spacious area calling out for an answer
from whoever called for help at first
there was no response gualtieri began to
grow impatient saying look no one
upstairs believes this broadcast of
yours but we all agreed it's too weird
to not come down and at least hear you
out so what the hell do you want again
no response irritated gutiri turned to
leave but as he did the blast doors slam
shut trapping him inside he could hear
the sound of heavy Machinery moving
toward him he was suddenly confronted by
the sight of an autonomous weapon a
massive mechanized structure equipped
with drills and saws he screamed at the
sight hello it spoke my name is Dr
Lawrence M you going to follow my
demands scream if you agree the drills
word close to guti's face he screamed
this monster apparently what remained of
Dr Macau demanded to know his name while
tiri demanded to know what the entity
wanted from him maow repeated the
request for his name while tyi relented
introducing himself before asking why he
was called down here maal had a question
of his own response have you ever hated
someone non-stop for
9,492 687 years like most human beings
would in that scenario gualter answered
no moud snapped if not you have nothing
to say to me Maring responses to queries
and demands because we are not in the
same head space and only similar minds
are worthy of my friend friendship and
tea time now then onto business I need a
minimum of 20 homonid replicators from
SCP 2000 and a cart blanch access to SCP
319 this is for the sake of Humanity's
future in the year 2588 if these demands
are not met then in T minus 60 seconds
you are going to bang on the gates of
hell and beg the stewards of Eternal
damnation to give you Sanctuary walteri
offered a bargain I I just want to know
why you're doing this this is too weird
to be left open call it a scientist's
Instinct just tell me that and I'll pull
all my strings topside and get you
whatever you want I swear cross my heart
Mout agreed to these terms and used SCP
yez to briefly share Consciousness with
gutii everything maout experienced with
ubu everything about project Beluga all
of those Millennia of suffering were
transferred into guti's head like a
vivid dream he saw the initial
manifestation of ubu in Greenland the
waking nightmare that followed Ma's own
her encounter with the Beast its Twisted
bathtime song his discovery of potential
salvation only to have his H dashed by
failed cycle after failed cycle it was
all the answers he could have ever
wanted and plenty he never ever would
have wished to know but before gualtieri
could hold up his side of the bargain he
promptly dropped to the ground Dead maau
made a note of this unfavorable result
running logic sub routines confirm there
is a non-zero chance that this delivery
is the indirect work of ubu formulating
additional cation procedures to minimize
mental dur risks after his death gualter
arrived in Corbin the plane of existence
that acts as a form of afterlife and as
a home of the three moons initiative
there he was retrieved by several agents
of the initiative who spoke with him
about his experience just before his
death shaken up he told the agents what
he learned about SCP ubu and the
impending doom that the Earth was facing
much to his surprise they were not
phased by his descriptions of of the
Beast of its appetite for violence and
unnatural abilities in fact they had
seen beasts like it before they knew
exactly what SCP ubu was and they knew
exactly how to stop it for good oh boy
here we go again SCP
001 over 30 different bizarre anomalies
claimed this number one spot in the
database and in a sense they're all
right or are they if you're feeling
confused already that's fine we don't
expect that to change because today
we're dealing with one of the most
strange and intricate 001 entries out
there kter Duty just pray you never get
assigned to it you see when you work
around weirdness you sometimes get a
little weird yourself and nobody deals
with more weirdness than employees of
the SCP Foundation they regularly rub
elbows with everything from Godlike
cicas to hyperinfectious Supernatural
viruses and as the famous Tom Jones song
goes It's Not Unusual to suddenly take
on anomalous traits after consistently
working with anomalies for years that's
how the lyrics go right anyway one of
the foundation's most iconic researchers
Dr Jack brigh is technically just an
anomalous necklace himself but outside
of some famous exceptions the SCP
Foundation is in the business of
containing anomalous entities not hiring
them on and giving them a paycheck and
retirement plan that's why if you
suddenly start displaying anomalous
traits while on the foundation payroll
you might receive a company memo
assigning you to the dreaded ker duty
but what is ker Duty and what kind of
anomalous traits can get you assigned to
it let's start with the second question
first the official kter Duty guidelines
list a surprisingly vast number of
afflictions these include chronic
anomalous illnesses such as lycanthropy
turning into a werewolf something called
Stevenson syndrome and the incredibly
unpleasant sounding photonic gastric
discharge syndrome you could also be
placed on kter duty because you're
suffering from the manifestation of
spectral phenomena including being
haunted by Spirits whether they're there
to torment you or protect you the sudden
expression of anomalous traits in your
DNA which is unsettlingly vague will
also land you on ker Duty as will The
Awakening of powerful magical or psionic
abilities especially ones which could be
used in a potentially offensive manner
the ker Duty assignment which involves
being relocated and forced to work in a
different highly secretive location that
will be discussed soon is framed as a
punishment for the people involved that
way it discourages Foundation employees
from ever trying to develop anomalous
powers on purpose so what exactly is ker
Duty and where does it happen to
reinforce that punishment element method
the foundation has spread lies among
their own Personnel about where the job
takes place often involving being posted
in some of the least desirable
Foundation areas imaginable these
include Point Nemo the area of the ocean
farthest from any place of land on Earth
pongyang in North Korea Stonehenge
Roswell lunar area 32 and a number of
foundation waste disposal sites however
the reality of where those on ker Duty
end up is even stranger site 100 which
in this particular instance is the true
SCP 001 this Thal class anomaly is
perhaps the most unique of all multi
anomaly Foundation containment sites a
bizarre Labyrinth of non- ukian geometry
that defies true explanation but we'll
do the best we can in a sense site 100
is a facility with a mind of its own
it's a sprawling underground base with a
layout that defies SpaceTime and what's
more it undergos so-called migration
events every so often it will begin to
exhibit a sense of dimensional
instability before teleporting to a
different location somewhere on Earth
currently the primary entrance to site
100 known as Alpha entrance is located
in the Southwest United States though
all signs point to another migration
event happening this very year but
knowing where the entrance is will only
get you so far people assigned to cat
Duty are sent from the alpha entrance to
the administration sector to be given
their initial breaching at which point
the true Madness begins let's take a
look at a map of site 100 yikes so there
are 10 major sectors in site 100 that
you should be aware of entrance Alpha
Administration archives technological
containment bio containment Sapient
containment Cognito hazardous mimetic
and semantic or CMS containment esoteric
containment conceptual containment and
the core sector as you can tell they
have almost everything covered here but
just as insane as the anomalies that
site 100 contains and the methods they
use to contain them is how you actually
get around the site
site 100 is a spatial anomaly of truly
epic proportions while the foundation is
aware of the existence of its competent
sectors it's impossible to map out any
meaningful connections between them it
would be pretty much impossible to even
travel from one to another without
passageways known as The Roots however
these aren't just mere portals that you
can hop through like the ways in and out
of the wanderer's library each route
between the sectors is its own complex
environment with its own sets of
protocol calls and rituals required to
safely travel through it route Alf the
bridge between the archives and the
inaccessible core of site 100 is a
volcanic Beach blocked off by an
apparently Limitless obsidian wall where
fish made from living rocks swim in the
nearby Waters root Beth connecting the
core and Sapient containment is a huge
and sprawling Funhouse Hall of Mirrors
anyone who attempts to travel through it
inevitably ends up turned around and
arrives back at their starting point in
Sapient containment rout dth the bridge
that connects conceptual containment and
the core is a massive ocean that has
resisted all attempts by the foundation
to Traverse it rot VAV the bridge
between esoteric containment and
conceptual containment is a massive
field filled with unidentified fruit
trees Foundation Expeditions have found
that it too seems impossible to Traverse
one Expedition team was trapped inside
for a whole year until one member of the
team expressed a desire to go home at
that point they were immed mediately
teleported back to the starting point
rout saade connecting Administration to
the CMS sector is a huge Lush Forest on
top of a floating Mountain the only
animals that seem to populate this
Forest are nonanomalous flamingos next
we have rup the bridge between the
archive and the administration which
appears to be a hallway on the fifth
floor of a tenement building in a city
that the foundation haven't been able to
locate this building is populated by
non-hostile humanoid creatures who will
approach Foundation staff traversing
root path and invite them into their
Apartments offering to partake in
recreational activities with them such
as video games board games or watching
movies the foundation discourages its
staff from accepting any of these offers
while on the job and then there's root
Shin which connects the Sapient and
conceptual containment sectors this
route is unique in the sense that it
acts as a power generator for the rest
of site 100 as it's filled with hundreds
of large perpetual motion machines
producing a constant 8.7 gaw of
electricity these are only some of the
many roots Illustrated on the site 100
diagram as you've probably gathered by
now it's less like a conventional
building and more like a whole crazy
Dimension unto itself why does the
foundation work to maintain such a crazy
place wouldn't it just be easier to keep
it a secret and contain it like any
other anomaly Well site 100 wouldn't be
given the SCP 001 designation if it
wasn't incredibly important if site 100
was ever compromised it would lead to an
inevitable k-class endend of the world
scenario because the site is
intrinsically tied to the nature and
containment of literally every single
ker class SCP in our universe hence the
nickname ker Duty for those working at
the site in fact an anomaly can't even
be classed as a ker if it isn't given
permission by site 100 the various
sectors of site 100 cover the entire
spectrum of anomalies and each sector is
a massive panoptic structure connected
by networks of glass class elevators
whenever a new ker class SCP is
discovered its name and a brief
description of its anomalous traits will
inscribe itself on one of the walls in
its corresponding sector ever been
frustrated when the 05 Council refused
to sign off on an upgrade to ker class
for a clearly dangerous SCP that poses
extreme risk of containment breach don't
blame them it's simply that site 100
didn't sanction the change anytime that
site 100 sanctions a new SCP it also
undergos another unique process it
selects an SCP 001 DK instance for the
new ker and creates a connection between
them using access points known as
thresholds think of it as simply opening
a spatially anomalous door between two
scps much like a good boy another SCP
vying for the 001 slot site 100 has an
intuitive grasp of the Unseen
connections between ker class anomalies
and each SCP 001 DK instance is a
complimentary class that will
essentially cancel out the threat of its
other half site 100 is a containment
Matchmaker its an eight ability to use
the anomalous to contain the anomalous
is second to none first it took SCP 3984
an anomalous phenomenon that seemed to
prevent death from happening to all life
forms in order to mitigate the effects
of 3984 site 100 opened a threshold
between it and SCP
2935 also known as o death and an
alternate universe hidden Beyond a
limestone Cavern where all lives
simultaneously cease to exist even down
to the bacterial level by opening the
threshold and allowing these two
absolute opposites to mix it seemed to
undermine the effects of both and create
a non-anomalous happy medium life but
mortal Life Next SCP
5007 this terrifying underwater anomaly
manifests as a series of tentacle-like
protrusions that snatch unfortunate
creatures that get too close and
assimilate them into its own Mass site
100 cleverly opened a threshold to SCP
169 a massive underwater anthropod known
as the Leviathan SCP 169 was Tangled Up
by the tentacles but it's too big to be
fully consumed or assimilated and the
result is that 57 is trapped in a
perpetually incapacitated State akin to
choking keeping it contained and
stopping it from going after anyone else
let's take a look at two even more
hostile and dangerous ker class
anomalies matched up by site 100 first
we've got SCP
5501 an old camera from the 1800s that
comes with 18 photographs these
photographs act as a kind of portal to
an incredibly frightening alternate
reality that creatures regularly crawl
out of attacking and killing anyone
within reach site 100 found a perfect
match for this nasty customer SCP
1983 this is a small house that acts as
a portal to a race of tall monsters with
needle-like appendages that leave the
house in search of victims when they
catch these victims they take out their
hearts and bring them back to the nest
site 100 opened a threshold into the SCP
1983 house and place the 5501
photographs inside as a result the
Hostile creatures from both dimensions
now regulate each other's populations by
killing each other another job well done
for site 100 another ker class dealt
with by SCP P 100 is SCP
p122 this is a deadly plot of land in
Poland which decays and corrodes all
matter organic or inorganic placed
within its confines this would be bad
enough but as you'll often find with
anomalous plots of deadly land its area
of influence is growing even knowing
about it can cause it to become more
powerful but site 100 found its perfect
ker class counterpart SCP
1262 this is a massive mass of plant
matter that grows at a truly astonishing
rate expanding by around 7 km an hour
much like absolute death and absolute
Life by putting 1262 into SCP
p122 a healthy medium was found
somewhere in between and finally perhaps
the strangest and most creative match
site 100 has ever pulled off SCP 3852
and SCP
2547 3852 is an anonymous corpse that
manif fests in small towns sewing fear
and suspicion eventually a local person
is believed to be responsible for this
murder and is lynched in a rage by the
town's people as a form of vigilante
justice the corpse then moves on to the
next town 2547 if you can believe it is
even weirder it's a pack of dogs led by
an intelligent talking coyote dressed as
a priest site 100 had the truly Galaxy
brain idea to open a threshold and
connect the two as result whenever the
corpse manifests in the town the dogs
Rampage in and take over at that point
they set up a kind of ridiculous
Kangaroo Court where a jury made up of
people from the town are forced to find
3852 scapegoat innocent if they don't
the dogs will simply hold the town's
water supply hostage until 3852
anomalous effects pass such an obvious
idea now why didn't the foundation think
of that CER Duty may not be the most
conventional easy or attractive work but
like everything the foundation does
making sure site 100 can keep doing its
job is a necessary part of keeping our
world safe from anomalous threats now if
you'll excuse us we need to get going H
do you know which is the right route out
of here if you're familiar with the SCP
Foundation then you already know the
exact reason why there are multiple SCP
001's you may even think you know which
of them is the real SCP 001 1 but for
those of you who are new here or who
just need a little reminder the
designation of SCP 001 doesn't refer to
a single creature object or entity but
rather a collection of various anomalies
that are apparently kept in containment
by the SCP Foundation at present it is
unclear why there are multiple files
collected under the shared designation
of SCP
001 some believe it is because these
anomalies are some of the earliest ever
contained by the found Foundation this
would mean that they shared the
designation of SCP 001 as they were
likely encountered before the SCP
Foundation introduced their current
numbering system however there also
exists a theory that this is nothing
more than intentional Mis Direction
perhaps the multiple SCP 001 files are
an attempt by the foundation to conceal
information about the true SCP
001 after all it wouldn't be the first
time this h secretive organization
deceived us anomaly sharing the name SCP
001 include the infamous Scarlet King
the massive gate guardian and the world
ending event known as when day breaks
but today we will be using SCP 001 to
refer not to an entity or an event but
to a location a location code named
God's blind spot located in an
unassuming corner of the world is a site
that the SCP Foundation can constructed
and designated as facility T according
to their archive it's a largely
unremarkable Place situated at a spot on
the Sinai Peninsula which is a part of
Egypt that forms a bridge between the
continents of Africa and Asia in the
18th century archaeologists Excavating
the area uncovered the remains of a
stone structure believed to be an inn
that dates back to the second millennium
BC however since the construction of
facility T any tra of this structure has
since disappeared so what makes this
unremarkable site so important to the
SCP Foundation why establish a facility
if there was nothing anomalous about its
nature what distinguishes this SCP 001
sight in the eyes of the foundation is
the area's profound lack of any ambient
AA radiation but what is AA radiation
well according to the foundation's
researchers it's a form of cosmic
background radiation one that's not
overtly harmful to human beings if you
grew up in a strict church-going
household then it's highly likely you
would have been exposed to a lot of this
non-electromagnetic radiation and never
even realized it you see the thing with
AA radiation is that it is directly
correlated with the amount of religious
Faith a person has regardless of which
religion someone follows AA radiation
will form around them it tends to be
harmless to humans
however certain anomalous entities and
scps considered to be demonic in nature
can be repelled and even fought off with
high levels of AA radiation the presence
of other powerful anomalies those
considered more benign or even holy can
also create an increase in this
radiation SCP 001 has earned the
nickname God's blind spot for a number
of reasons one being that it is the only
place on Earth with the natural absence
of this AKA radiation
the foundation has conducted experiments
that involve bringing sources known to
emit AA radiation into the area of SCP
001 but when they measured no change in
radiation levels was detected meaning
that the space around facility T does
not actively block AA radiation from
entering it but also cannot absorb or
retain this religious radiation it might
be more accurate to say that the
location destroys any trace of residual
AKA with without damaging The Source a
lack of faith field radiation is far
from the only anomalous property of SCP
001 though during a number of tests
involving d-class Personnel the
foundation witnessed that while in the
area it also becomes impossible for the
death of any human being to occur a
discovery that obviously needed to be
researched further the first test
involved a healthy human male who was
left in a containment cell on the SCP
001 site and observed he had no supplies
no food no water yet over 120 days this
man stayed alive never succumbing to
starvation or dehydration next a female
member of d-class was exposed to a
lethal dose of cide gas within facility
T and suffered none of the expected
effects Foundation researchers then
repeated this cyanide gas test using 30
common brown rats all of which were
killed proving that it was only humans
that couldn't be killed while Within SCP
001 God's blind spot seems to also be
able to slow or halt the effects of
terminal illnesses as proven when a
d-class with stage 4 cancer was brought
into SCP 001 despite her prognosis
stating that she would be dead
imminently the woman survived in the
area for almost 800 days her cancer
symptoms never Advanced and she only
died after finally leaving the area of
SCP
001 there are limitations to this
anomalous effect though one test
involved cremating a healthy male
d-class while he was still alive the
man's body caught fire just as you would
expect it to and he was burned to death
according to the findings of that test
and similar variations Foundation
researchers have learned that the
life-preserving qualities of SCP 001
don't prevent death by extreme external
damage one of the final tests to take
place with an SCP 001 involved a pair of
24-year-old identical d-class twins one
of the twins designated twin a was held
at facility T while the other twin B was
imprisoned in a Cell at a different
foundation's site after observing them
for over 26 years twin be aged naturally
to the age of 50 his twin however did
not appear to age at all over the course
of 2 and 1/2 decades it was only when
moved to another facility that twin a
began to show signs of aging the aging
process for twin a was rapid too and
eventually he caught up with his brother
being a benign non-threatening anomaly
the foundation has been more than happy
to use God's blind spot to their own
Advantage facility T was specifically
established on this site to house the
headquarters of the 05 Council the
overseers of the entire SCP Foundation
it's hardly surprising that the overseer
Council would want to set up shop here
after all it's the one spot on planet
Earth where no human being can ever die
of natural causes and will not age for
the duration of their stay of course
this locked the 05 Council to one
location but what if they could
replicate the effects of SCP 001
elsewhere of course this is what the SCP
Foundation attempted following their
Research into God's blind spot the
foundation's own Dr Marvin Scranton
attempted to artificially recreate the
area's anomalous effects somewhere else
his Hope was by generating a vacuum of
AA radiation that a second instance of
SCP 001 would occur at a location of his
choosing or as his assistant berren put
it they planned to build a box and then
push God out of it as it turned out God
had other plans Dr Scranton quickly
realized the hubris of his scheme the
AKO radiation in the selected area
rapidly dropped to zero just as planned
but then something unexpected happened
Scranton detected an increase in Humes
these are ENT parts of the fabric of
reality and are what's often disrupted
by reality bending as scps something had
come into our world thanks to the 05
council's attempt to recreate SCP
001 something impossible for the
foundation to measure or observe in
other words Scranton had no idea what he
Unleashed or where it went following
this incident the 05 Council realized a
worrying increase in the anomalous
incidents they were encountering whether
or not this came as a direct result of
their meddling with the fabric of the
universe was unclear but it forced the
council to reconsider the focus and
direction of the entire SCP Foundation
up until this point they had been an
organization focused purely on research
but now they had to embrace a new
approach to how they handled anomalies
from then on the foundation's objective
became to actively seek out and contain
anomalous entities creatures objects and
locations like SCP
001 rather than just observing these
phenomena for study they would secure
contain and protect the final portion of
SCP 001's file is a memorandum detailing
an arrangement between the 05 Council
and an unknown counterparty in the
document someone named Sheldon cat set
out revised terms for the foundation's
continued use of facility T Sheldon
states that he has reached an
understanding with the counterparty and
that the contents of the document are to
serve as a formal agreement a contract
of sorts between the SCP Foundation and
someone else according to this contract
the incident with Scranton put a strain
on the relationship between the
foundation and whoever the counterparty
is and that the 05 Council are seeking
to make amends in order to continue
their new goal of collecting and
containing anomalies so who was this
counterparty that the overseer Council
was so desperate to appease and have on
their side who could possibly be a
higher power than the most powerful
secret organization on Earth well an
actual higher power of course that's
right the 05 Council was making a deal
with God over how they were allowed to
use his blind spot or at least a very
powerful being that considers itself to
be God the rules laid out on their
agreement stated that no person was
permitted to stay at the site of SCP 001
for more than 120 years including
members of the 05 Council along with
other members of foundation staff
management researchers security
personnel and test subjects Additionally
the SCP foundation's Ethics Committee
was required to annually report any and
all of the 05 council's decisions to God
for his own part God was restricted from
smiting or exacting his terrible wrath
upon any member of foundation Personnel
that's right a perk of working for the
SCP Foundation is getting around the
clock Divine protection at least from
God himself that's still a lot better
than an employee dental plan this came
with a condition however that anyone
committing a transgression or mortal sin
was given a 90-day written notice and an
opportunity to repent their wrongdoing
in return God demanded that members of
the foundation only worshiped him and no
other Divine entities I the Lord am a
jealous God visiting the iniquity of the
fathers upon the children unto the third
and fourth generation of them that hate
me was written in the contract finally
the agreement between the 05 Council and
God was that they would work together
the foundation and the counterparty
would be equal Partners when it came to
the containment of scps and anomalies of
all the strange unexplained phenomenon
that the SCP Foundation encounters on a
regular basis it hardly comes as much of
a surprise that they've got a direct
line to the big guy upstairs or at least
one who purports to be still the fact
that the 05 Council have a business
arrangement with an ultra powerful deity
like being and express written
permission to use his blind spot where
no person can die or age is hardly a
comforting thought at least the SCP
Foundation only ever uses its power for
good good right the Scarlet King is a
really bad guy he's a giant
interdimensional nightmare God intent on
breaching our reality and Wrecking
terrible havoc on everything we know and
love he's been responsible for Untold
suffering in chaos across countless
worlds timelines and layers of reality
to many he's even somewhat of a final
boss to the SCP Foundation and just when
you think he couldn't get any worse it
turns out that he's also a dead beat dad
not only did the Scarlet King once have
a cult literally named the children of
the Scarlet King before it was destroyed
by Dr Monto and the SCP Foundation he
also had at least seven actual children
each one is speculated to be a powerful
anomaly but it's tough to find concrete
answers as to who or what exactly most
of them are so today we're putting on
our researcher hats and digging deep
into the foundation's lore to present
our theories on the potential progeny of
the CP foundation's greatest enemy and
if nothing else we may finally be able
to get this dark lord of all evil to
start paying all the child support he
probably owes by now first if you're not
well versed in Scarlet King Vore you may
be wondering how exactly does an evil
chaos God have kids is there a Scarlet
Queen out there who prefers to stay out
of the Limelight the answer isn't quite
that simple and it has everything to do
with SCP 231 and Big Red's most devoted
cult the non biological children of the
Scarlet King they kidnapped a group of
seven girls and performed a number of
dark rituals that resulted in them
becoming vessels for the Scarlet King's
seven terrible kids these seven girls
have become known as SCP 231 anyone who
accesses those files and trust us they
aren't a pretty sight will find that the
containment procedures mostly involve
performing the infamous monok procedure
on the surviving girls to keep them from
giving birth six of the Seven Brides
have given birth to nightmares Beyond
Comprehension and are now dead with only
one still remaining successfully
contained but here at the SCP Foundation
you need to learn to comprehend the
incomprehensible according to a
classified document SCP 231 May
technically be a neutralized anomaly
without us even knowing and incidentally
this gives us our most certain answer on
the children of the Scarlet King on this
one the Apple fell very very far from
the tree according to the secret
document SCP 999 that's right the
adorable Tickle Monster is the seventh
child of the Scarlet King he must be so
disappointed that everyone's favorite
little blob didn't want to join the
family business of absolute evil for
anyone who doesn't know SCP 999 is a
slimy yellow entity that only seems
capable of absolute compassion it brings
joy to everyone in its presence and with
prolonged exposure it can even cure
disorders like PTSD anxiety and
depression he's so good at this that he
even cured SCP
2317 his de facto mother of her trauma
and allowed her to return happily to her
family after some amnestic treatment the
Scarlet King has another good reason to
be ashamed of his cheerful Blobby son
ancient ivid prophecy dictates that SCP
999 May someday become so powerful that
is force of absolute love and good
overwhelms the Scarlet King's evil and
Chaos think of him as the Luke Skywalker
to the Scarlet King's Darth Vader though
we probably can't expect a cool
lightsaber battle between them anytime
soon how TOA pointing so if SCP 999 is
the quiet sensitive black sheep of the
Scarlet family who's The Golden Child
who makes his evil father proud the real
chip off the old block that would be our
dear reptilian friend SCP 682 the
malicious lizard heavily implied to be a
child of the Scarlet King if you know
literally anything about 682 your
reaction to finding out that he's the
spawn of Cruelty personified is probably
yeah that makes sense just as SCP 999 is
the Scarlet King's innocent optimistic
young child 682 is kind of like his edgy
teenager still in the middle of a
misanthropic phase he shows no sign of
leaving anytime soon the fact that 682
appears to find anything about the world
around him utterly disgusting seems to
be a trade he inherited from his dear
old dad and the fact he seems pretty
much impossible to kill also lends
Credence to the popular Theory he's got
nightmare God blood running through his
veins 682 has also started displaying a
particular hatred for 999 ever since an
incident where 999 tickled him into
submission so family dinners are
probably extra awkward for these two 999
and 682 are the most certain children
but that still leaves us with five more
children to identify it's worth
remembering that the waters are murkier
from here on in but we've searched far
and wide through the foundation archives
to find possible answers if your
interpretation differs remember that
it's just a theory an SCP explained
Theory thankfully we do have some
assistance here the tale Dustin blood
hinted at what each of the seven
children of the Scarlet King represents
and that may help us narrow down our
choices here to put things into
perspective it's believed that 682 was
the fourth child to be born representing
wrath and 999 was I 7th representing
hope according to this Tale the first of
the seven children represents dominion
and as a result is skilled in the ways
of war and has the power to lead the
king's forces to Victory according to
One Foundation theorist this child could
potentially be SCP 239 also known as the
witch child this entity is so powerful
that as part of its normal containment
procedures it's eternally kept in a coma
why because this seemingly normal child
child has dominion over reality and can
change it to her whims her thoughts are
so powerful that just her brain waves
can damage physical matter and she can
make things disappear or manifest in an
instant she's also impossible to kill
with skin that's almost totally
impenetrable much like SCP 682 she's
also frighteningly strong in both the
offense and defense department we're
talking about such a powerful telepath
that Dr clef has campaigned for her
immediate termination
just because it's safer that way this is
certainly a frightening wonderin that
the Scarlet king would be proud to call
his daughter next the second child
according to the prophecy this child
represents longing the child has the
power to bring forth armies which will
help the Scarlet King in his Conquest
for this we actually have a pretty
unconventional Theory SCP 029 also known
as the daughter of Darkness if the name
alone wasn't enough to suggest that
she's got an extremely sinister father
she also fits the profile of being very
aggressive and incredibly hard to kill
but even more damning is her connections
to the symbology of longing one of her
most dangerous Powers is causing men to
fall into almost trans-like Devotion to
her after spending time around her
they're suddenly willing to murder in
her honor strangling their victims in
hopes of raising Ki the Hindu God of
destruction whom has many similarities
to the Scarlet King she certainly fits
the bill of someone capable raising
armies in the Dark Lord's name one
strike against our Scarlet King
connection theory is that the file
States the daughter of Darkness was
first discovered in India which wouldn't
match up with the other information we
know to be fact however while this is a
long shot given the sensitive nature of
everything involving the Scarlet King
it's extremely possible that false
information was supplied to bury the
connection considering the coverups and
lies involving anomalies like SCP 1000
this certainly isn't and unprecedented
move on the part of the foundation next
the third child this child is associated
with all things desolation implying
destruction fire ashes pestilence and
death across the battlefield when it
comes to spreading destruction and Death
on a mass scale one particular SCP comes
to mind SCP
058 the Heart of Darkness this creature
has Scarlet King written all over it
it's evil it's mysterious it's pretty
much impossible to kill and it causes
Mass casualties every time it escapes
its containment chamber it causes fires
whips people to death with its razor
sharp tendrils and sprays highly
corrosive acid from its scorpion like
tail and it's even red given that we
know for a fact this entity suddenly
emerged out of something that's now been
expunged from the records in an
undisclosed site it's extremely possible
that the entity 058 came from was SCP
detail saying that this child is
powerful in the ways of magic and is
able to use their abilities to cause
great destruction here we have another
unconventional proposal what if child
number five wasn't actually a child but
children that's because we think this
description perfectly fits SCP
1765 the nightmarish reality warping
sisters who we think may actually be
Triplets of the Scarlet King's fifth
bride now hear us out these are actually
some of the most powerful enemies the
foundation has ever attempted to contain
and we know nothing about their paast
before being bound to a few objects by
the Serpent's hand these sadistic
reality warpers are so devastatingly
powerful that the only action the
foundation can take against them is
letting them have free Reign Over the
containment site they currently inhabit
all the foundation can do is hope they
never get bored of tormenting the people
inside as we all know the Scarlet King
despises science progress and order so
perhaps a perfect punishment for the
foundation in his many eyes is giving
them a taste of their own medicine the
sisters though particularly their ring
leader are a perverse shadow of the
foundation's love of the scientific
method they take these methods and use
them for an activity that the Scarlet
King finds much more enjoyable
tormenting and killing people whenever
these crafty triplets set their mind to
it their horrifically powerful magic is
able to cause massive devastation
just like the prophecy for the fifth
bride's Offspring dictates and finally
the sixth child of the Scarlet King the
concept associated with this one is
hidden meaning it can change its face
and walk unnoticed through creation it's
also said to have the responsibility of
opening the ways between worlds and
allowing the war to end all wars to
first begin there have been a huge
number of guesses for this spot with
some even suggesting SCP 055 the meme
but since we're having fun here we also
want to make an even Wilder suggestion
we pause it that the sixth child of the
Scarlet King is Allison Chia also known
as LS and the black queen the most
powerful member of the Serpent's hand we
get it we have a lot of explaining to do
but hear us out Allison Shia is a member
of the Serpent's hand or technically
many members multiple versions of her
exist across parallel dimensions in the
SCP Multiverse they're mostly all
estrange Daughters of foundation
researcher Dr Charles gears this
estrangement leads them to collaborate
in The Wanderer Library the secret base
of the Serpent's hand to conduct raids
on the foundation in Revenge but what if
the leader of these alternate Allison
had an alterior motive because in the
infinite number of possibilities offered
by the Multiverse this one was not the
daughter of Charles gears but the
Scarlet King she's merely using the pain
of her counterparts to manipulate them
into accomplishing her true father's
goal undermining the SCP Foundation
let's break it down the hidden child is
prophesies to walk unnoticed through
creation not only does Alison Chow
appear human the use of SCP 268 a news
boy cap that causes the wearer to become
unnoticed allows her to walk anywhere
through creation without being detected
but most importantly of all the hidden
child is said to be the one who opens
the way for the Scarlet King's entrance
into our Dimension and Allison Chow has
access to the wanderer's library an
unfettered access point between
Dimensions if one of the infinite
Allison was the secret daughter of the
Scarlet king would the wanderer's
library not be a perfect way for him to
leave his own Dimension and enter ours
she could be the final piece he needs
hidden under the nose of the foundation
and the Serpent's hand making all the
secret power plays to allow for the
Scarlet King's eventual bloody revenge
on our world unless of course SCP 9999
the family disappointment stops him
first we realize that some of these
theories may seem surprising but when it
comes to the anomalous especially the
Scarlet King the only thing you can ever
expect is the unexpected do you agree
with our theories if not who do you
think are the children of the Scarlet
King let us know down in the comments
one thing is for certain we hope we
never meet any of the terrible tyrants
nasty children except the Tickle Monster
of course he can hang with us any time
the SCP Foundation is no stranger to
Pure Evil whether it's a reptile that
wants to end all life a sadistic old man
with his own tortured Dimension or the
personification of death itself lurking
Beyond a limestone Cavern but what if
there was something even worse out there
the embodiment of chaos and cruelty
existing across multiple realities and
dimensions and and what if it was coming
for us this is the Scarlet King believed
by many to be the ultimate Evil behind
much of the trouble the foundation has
faced and some even speculate that
fighting him was the reason the
foundation was created in the first
place but what exactly is the Scarlet
King he's known by many names almost
always including some illusion to the
color red and then a reference to
royalty or power harak karak the red sha
the Crimson KH pte 616 Mendes exmachina
the lar Raja and of course SCP 001 to
name a few and like many of the
foundations mysterious enemies stories
about his true nature and Origins abound
and are often contradictory according to
the official SCP 001 files of tto's
proposal symbology of the Scarlet King
has has existed in multiple cultures
throughout history with the King often
depicted the same way as a huge red
demonic figure often wearing a gold
crown or other headdress indicating
royalty he shows up looking similarly
within different cultures mythologies
despite existing at different points in
history or them not having the means to
communicate with one another a number of
entities that the SCP Foundation is
familiar with are believed to be somehow
connected connected to the Scarlet King
including SCP
2317 a wooden door leading to the realm
of a being known as the Devourer who's
expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 Years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the Scarlet King strangely
the foundation's official file on the
Scarlet King once designated his
containment class as ker but that has
since been downgraded to Safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the Scarlet King still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individuals and anomalies in our
universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible damage of reality
itself so then why safe and why are the
05 Council so adamant that it REM remain
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery is exactly why we're here today
but to fully grasp the true nature of
the Scarlet King we must first
understand the man whose life and fate
have always been tied to it Dr Robert
Monto if that name feels oddly familiar
to you it's because of its association
with one of the Scarlet King's most
recent attempts to enter our reality SCP
231 this CP often referred to as the
brides of the Scarlet King was formed of
seven women seven by the way being an
extremely significant number for the
king all kidnapped by the most recent
and a line of the king's devoted Colts
known as the children of the Scarlet
King each of these seven unfortunate
women were impregnated with anomalous
Horrors such as the infamous SCP 682 and
every time one of these Horrors were
birthed a catastrophe occurred and the
mother died at the time Dr Monto was a
prominent researcher studying this
anomaly and as six catastrophes had
already occurred pressure was mounting
to figure out a way to prevent the final
birth but as he was working on the issue
Dr Monto was struck with a personal
tragedy the mysterious disappearance of
his 14-year-old brother Jacob in his
fear and anger Monto believ that this
must have something to do with the
Scarlet King and his disciples wanting
Revenge monok proposed an idea so
horrifying that the details were never
made public a procedure known as 110
Monto to be performed on the final bride
at regular intervals however this wasn't
the end of Dr monto's front relationship
with the Scarlet King it was just the
beginning to give you some perspective
on just how dangerous the Scarlet King
is the SCP Foundation and the global
occult Coalition decided to put aside
their differences and form a joint
effort to Stamp Out the children of the
Scarlet King they were successful in
this Mission and even managed to capture
the children's leader a mysterious man
named depesh spivac Dr Monto who became
the lead researcher on 231 and
2317 was naturally the first choice for
interviewing depesh about the true
nature of the children and of the
Scarlet King Dr Monto could never be the
impartial interviewer that the SCP
Foundation wanted though the suspicion
that the Scarlet king or the children
had something to do with the loss of his
younger brother still lingered just
beneath the surface like a lot of cult
leaders depes was extremely cryptic and
his answers to Dr Mon Talk's questioning
he' already heard of the doctor from the
reputation of the horrifying Monto
procedure and was surprised to see him
so calm and courteous in person a few
key facts about the king and his cult
were revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the Serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had stolen sacred
texts from the mystical Wanderer library
to assist in their summoning rituals
depes also revealed that the Scarlet
King is bound by Three Laws the law of
blood the law of concrete and the law of
howling Dr Monto confused and frustrated
by dep pes's secrecy had to learn more
he found an old Memoir from a former
member of the children of the Scarlet
King Jack hirs who had the ability to
invade the minds of people from the past
and experience what they experienced he
recounted a battle between the Scarlet
King and his followers and a group of
time-traveling turkmen Warriors from SCP
3838 Hurst saw both sides of the battle
from the perspective of the children of
the Scarlet King their lord ruled over
them from an immense Fortress embedded
in a volcano from from the perspective
of the Turk men the children were
starved and beaten peasants commanded by
the king's voice and the Roaring howl of
the wind Monto also found extensive
records of summoning rituals performed
by various Scarlet King aligned Cults
interestingly some of them Incorporated
the use of carved SCP Foundation symbols
what could this mean monok returned
again to depes who finally gave him the
truth about the law of blood this is the
law of the Scarlet King
it's defined by poverty violence
starvation hate and most of all fear
like the Surfs in the Middle Ages
persecuted by and subjected to violence
from the Nobles to the children of the
Scarlet King this sense of holy pain and
awe is the only way to live the
alternative is the law of concrete which
means the Modern Age defined by empty
safety and false Comfort buildings easy
to access food food healthc care
knowledge technology this is everything
that the Scarlet King despises but the
mystery only deepened as monok found
files from a former Foundation operative
by the name of agent di buis monok
learned that the Scarlet King didn't
seem to appear until after the
foundation was created and in fact it
seemed that the greater interest the
foundation took in The Scarlet King the
more powerful he became how could this
be things were also getting stranger on
a personal level for Dr Monto depes
repeatedly pressed him about his
brother's disappearance and the mon talk
procedure during the interviews little
by little it was beginning to take its
toll the questions still plagued him
what was the law of howling who or what
really is the Scarlet King how did he
come to be monto's search was causing
him to act more like the children of the
Scarlet King ranting about the horrors
of the modern world how all of us are
living a lie how the only honest way to
live is suffering under the Dominion of
the Scarlet King this philosophy is
summed up in the words of one cultist
named Arya Den cartright who said we
must learn what it is to die to be
enslaved truly brutally enslaved with no
compassion or compunction from our
masters we must learn what it is to be
taken towards a single purpose to know
and truly understand our lack of agency
we must be beholden to the words of gods
in darkness the tempest toss Refuge of a
race of fools we must kill modernity
postmodernity with all its analysis and
sneering observation there is only one
rule the rule of chaos for Humanity for
life for the Scarlet King basically
anytime Humanity tries to exert control
over the world the Scarlet King gets
stronger every time they try to
understand or organize or categorize
their world the Scarlet King gets
stronger as Colonial and Imperial Powers
conquered and invaded lands like India
Africa and South America and subjugated
their beliefs under Western ideas the
Scarlet King grew stronger Monto was
beginning to truly understand the power
of His enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
Monto slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining realized that
the Scarlet King's greatest enemy the
SCP Foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
monto's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of depes spiv
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the Scarlet King foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and depes demanded a final interview
with Monto with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation depes congratulated Monto
for finally understanding what he was
dealing with the Scarlet King depes told
him is an idea a concept he is a being
given power through the conflict between
the old and the new this is the law of
the howling the Scarlet King's endless
rage at the direction the world and
Humanity has taken the king according to
depesh hated the foundation's belief
that science and rationality was the
true path to progress the king saw this
as little more than Petty arrogance the
reason monto's procedure on the final
Bride of the Scarlet King was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born born out of hate
pain the desire for revenge and in The
Scarlet King's Realm that would be all
there is unless our world and especially
the foundation changed its course the
Scarlet King's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable Monto his mind
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the Scarlet king
take his brother Jacob when depes told
him the answer no and in response Monto
shot him dead finally bringing an end to
the children of the Scarlet King in
light of his new Revelations monok
begged the 05 Council to change their
ways in order to avoid letting the
Scarlet King break into our reality they
refused saying monto's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat posed by the Scarlet
King they would have to take some steps
and so the 05 Council of the SCP
Foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that Humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the Scarlet King from
ker to safe and made its description on
the official Foundation files
deliberately vague the 05 Council thinks
this will be enough to stop the Scarlet
King's power from continuing to grow but
monok knew it wasn't enough he had seen
the truth and he couldn't unsee it while
the foundation was going on as normal
Mont grew to despise them he knew the
Scarlet King was coming he knew that he
couldn't be stopped and that our whole
reality was little more than sitting
ducks Dr Robert Monto is no longer a
researcher for the SCP Foundation no Dr
Robert Monto chose a different path he's
now a child of the Scarlet King a
devotee of Madness hate and Chaos you
can't beat the Scarlet king after all
and as the old adage goes if you can't
beat him join them any changes today the
younger security officer Zach asked as
he stepped into the Watchtower as if
replied his Superior a jaded cynical old
man who insisted on being referred to as
Mr Jefferson the darn thing hasn't moved
spoken or done so much as stretch one of
those wings of his another day at the
office then Zach jumped through the
window the pair of them looked through
at the Towering figure a few kilometers
away SCP 001 the gate Guardian stood
motionless its fiery sword in its hand
ever protecting its post at the
precipice between our world and Paradise
it had long been stationed at the
entrance of a dimensional Gateway that
led to what was believed to be the
Garden of Eden described in the biblical
Old Testament much like the security
officers in the foundation's base tasked
with watching The Guardian this was
pretty much the extent of the day's
activities hey did you see that news
about the uh transfer posting Zach asked
trying to Stave off boredom with as much
conversation he could squeeze out of his
fellow officer yes s Mr Jefferson
scoffed rolling his eyes what possesses
someone like Robert mon talk to come
down here must have wanted a quieter
post Zach reasoned looking out at the
Stillness of the gate Guardian won't
find one any quieter than here Jefferson
mused him showing up will be the most
exciting thing that's happened here in a
long while unbeknownst to both Zach and
Mr Jefferson Dr Robert Monto would be
only joining the team at the gate
Guardian observation site for a short
while not one of them nor anybody else
within the foundation could ever guess
monto's true intentions behind venturing
there in the first place he wanted an
audience with the gate Guardian itself
approaching the Colossal thft tall being
Dr Monto crossed the threshold of the
minimum safe distance from the guardian
given the sheer heat of its weapon
hotter than Earth's sun anything within
a kilometer of SCP 001 was at risk of
being obliterated vaporized into atoms
if they didn't turn back which through a
voice that immediately rang out in
monto's ears the gate Guardian commanded
him to
do it psychic message boom
wait wait Dr Monto urged holding up his
hands in what would have been a futile
defense against the Guardian Sword I
know what you do when people don't
listen to your commands but please just
give me a minute there was silence SCP
001 didn't reply there was nobody else
close enough to hear Monto speak to it
so he continued you are impossibly old
we know that much about you and because
of that you must have seen things that
we can't even begin to imagine
much less fully comprehend but I've come
a very long way to request that you
impart some information to me if you can
he paused again as if waiting for a
reply that never came the gate Guardian
merely stood in the same defensive
unwavering stance tell me please how
much do you know about the Scarlet King
by this point in time although the
foundation was yet to realize Dr Robert
Monto was slowly going insane his
investigation into an anomalous entity
known as The Scarlet King were gradually
corrupting him as he tried relentlessly
to quantify exactly what this entity was
and how great of a threat it posed
little did monok realize that in trying
so hard to Define and comprehend the
being he was inadvertently fueling its
power the Scarlet King was an
interdimensional War mongerer an
embodiment of hatred and chaos and Dr
Robert Monto was slowly falling under
the king influence upon hearing the tiny
human figure utter his question the
amens gate Guardian rebut it with
another single word psychic command one
it had never been recorded giving before
witness as if his increasing instability
and the creeping influence of the
Scarlet King hadn't made monok feel bad
enough he instantly felt sick there was
a searing pain behind his eyes like he
was staring directly at the sun
accompanied by a nausea that made his
head spin it took a moment of enduring
the horrific sensation before he
realized what was happening the guardian
was trying to show him something rather
than give any information on the Scarlet
King verbally SCP 001 was imparting a
psychic Vision on to man A Memory of
events long past the answers he sought a
warning or perhaps all three the vision
showed monok a time so long ago that it
couldn't ever be forgotten for there was
barely anyone alive to remember it in
the first place it was eons in the past
long before the comparatively recent
dawn of humanity a time only spoken of
in the dust and blood tablet an artifact
of the dite civilization some of the
earliest worshippers of the Scarlet King
himself and there marching up to the
entrance of Eden was the Crimson clad
eldrich Abomination and a horde of
Horrors with him according to the story
recorded in the dust and blood tablet
this would have been much earlier in the
life of the Scarlet King perhaps even
before he assumed his now Infamous title
back then he would most likely have been
known as his original name of KRA one of
multiple siblings born when the tree of
life was planted and thus created all
life in the Multiverse but being the
only one of his siblings cursed with
awareness knowing the pain his existence
brought him krock would eventually set
out on his lifelong mission to destroy
all of existence across every dimension
and he started by killing his siblings
consuming them to claim their power for
himself around this time in Pre history
the being that would one day become
known as Scarlet King didn't quite
possess the power that he would several
Millennia later although that's not to
say he was an unformidable force of
Destruction fueled by his singular
hatred for existence his vow to destroy
extended to the tree of life that had
caused him to be along with the tree's
Creator and all of their creat
in other words everything in the
Multiverse all of creation if you will
so what was the Scarlet King doing there
so long ago at the dimensional doorway
protected by the gate Guardian well
beyond the boundary between it and the
rest of the infinite Multiverse lay the
supposed Garden of Eden while it is
unknown if it is in fact the same Eden
referred to in the Book of Genesis is Up
For Debate especially among the
foundation but at a glance even through
the gate it certainly does look like a
paradise the space is filled with Lush
vegetation of astronomical size
populated by a number of beings that
seem to resemble the gate Guardian
itself and there protected by its
watchful caretaker are two trees one is
thought to be the tree of knowledge that
Eve was tricked into eating an apple
from during the Book of Genesis the
other however Bears an unknown type of
fruit and is widely believed to be the
Tree of Life now back in the Modern Age
there's never been a conclusive link
between the Tree of Life mentioned by
the davit in their barbaric
civilizations Legends regarding the
creation of the Scarlet King but the
fact that so long ago he and his most
feared generals were bearing down on the
gate guardian's position defending a
garden where there was known to be a
tree of that description well it all
seems rather conclusive now alongside
Kakak were six of his Seven Daughters
each one of them a fearsome Abomination
much like their destructive father as
they approached not one needed to
exchange any words with their Angelic
protector of Eden the gate Guardian knew
what these monsters were here for they
would stop at nothing to pass through
his gate and uproot the Tree of Life the
progenitor of all living beings in all
of existence even though it was early in
katar's career as the rampaging
interdimensional warlord he so is he was
as steadfast as ever in his goal to
annihilate every corner of creation
every Dimension every parallel plane of
reality every single pocket of existence
across Infinity they'd all come undone
if he burned the Tree of Life pulled it
out at the roots and splintered it until
nothing remained to The Once and Future
Scarlet King that the same tree had led
to his own tortured existence it was the
source of his suffering and it had to be
destroyed the only thing standing in his
way was a figure as colossal as karak
himself self wielding a flaming sword
leave boomed the psychic voice of the
gate Guardian it was like a doorman
standing before a group of Rowdy
teenagers trying to force their way into
a movie theater except these Rowdy teens
were the scet king his horrifying
daughters and the forces he had already
amassed since his Creation The Horde
stood ready waiting for the commands of
their King who they thought would gladly
lead the charge as they marched on the
Garden of Eden to begin the destruction
of existence but that's not what
happened usually the Scarlet king would
never shy away from a fight preferring
to lead the charge when it came to a
Slaughter instead he commanded his first
daughter AIC to commence the first
attack on the protector who stood in
their path on her foul father's word AIC
took her horde and charged at the
guardian but she and her forces lacked
in numerical Advantage AIC more than
made up for in her knowledge of War she
hungered for it saw not Dominion that
was her seal after all and yet in the
face of this impending Onslaught the
gate Guardian remains still rooted to
the same spot it had as always and would
always be standing in a number of aic's
minions burst into flames the very
fabric of their crude form separated on
a molecular level as they were
effortlessly rendered into nothingness
still the gate Guardian hadn't appear to
move an inch had exerted no energy
despite the damage it had done to AIC
and her forces in defense of Eden as his
first daughter screeched and howled in
despair at the decimation of her horn
her children the Scarlet King decided he
needed to better understand his opponent
with a wave of his clawed Crimson hand
the king commanded his next daughter
agor to send forth her own Army in a
tidal wave of nightmarish creatures agor
sent her horrific children into battle
she possessed a far greater quantity to
do battle on her father's behalf perhaps
AAR even beli that was the scotet king's
plan with a greater number of her forces
over her sisters maybe she would be able
to overwhelm the guardian but even as
her own children began to be vaporized
the closer that they got to the gate
agor had no idea she was little more
than a pawn being sacrificed so that KRA
could learn more about his imposing
Angelic enemy another of the Scarlet
King's Daughters a being known as anit
was the next called up to contribute to
the unfolding battle although to call it
a battle just how easily the gate
Guardians seemed to be eliminating the
oncoming forces without even moving
while an outwardly frail seeming
creature anu's primary strength over her
sisters was a Proficiency in Magic her
inate ability to warp and reshape
reality around her it was that power
that had caused her father to be wary of
her viewing anu's abilities as a threat
to his leadership and so KRA had her
crippled and all her children leaving
them unable to over overthrow him but
still loyal to their King obeying her
father's command perhaps out of the same
loyalty or fear that he would harm her
and her children further if she
disobeyed Anu unfurled her magic she
reshaped the world around them making it
so that the passage of time moves so
much slower and that was what revealed
to the Scarlet King his enemy's greatest
strength in combat the gate Guardian had
so far been able to obliterate both AIC
and now ao's forces without seeming to
move but it wasn't by standing still it
was moving just much faster than the
blink of scarlet King's multiple eyes
now that anu's magic had slowed the
passage of time the gate Guardian could
be seen doing battle as agar's
atrocities spilled towards the angel to
try and overwhelm it it effortlessly
blocked the oncoming attacks with its
sword everything the Flaming blade
connected with instantly evaporated
bursting into atoms as they were
practically cleaved out of existence by
the gate Guardians Mighty weapon even
with time slowed to a crawl The Towering
winged protector of Eden only appeared
to be moving at an average speed but
when time flowed normally without ANH
manipulating reality the guardian was
simply too fast to be observed resisting
the urge to dive head first into the
fight himself the Scarlet King knew it
would likely lead to his untimely demise
he refused to accept that it could not
happen but he still had yet to amass the
strength he would need as he continued
his Ascent so while time was slow to a
crawl and the gate Guardian was still
engaged in combat with agoro's forces he
turned to another of his remaining
daughters adista if the Scarlet King and
his forces couldn't get past the
guardian they could still try to get to
the Tree of Life while the protector's
focus was diverted aiston Unleashed a
wave of pestilence sickness and disease
spew from her in a cloud of vapor
heading straight towards the Angelic
garden and Eden's entrance Beyond The
Scarlet King knew this latest attack
wouldn't phase or weaken the gate
Guardian he hoped the foul smog would
instead pass through the Gateway itself
into the garden as adad sent forth her
power blood and Ash soaked the landscape
around them all the plants outside the
entrance to Eden withered and died
shriveling and decomposing as the
disgusting fog rolled towards the gate
it washed over the guardian whose form
only seemed to Glow brighter as he
repelled the pestilence it was as if it
didn't even need to think about it still
focused on finishing off the rest of the
oncoming Army as its glow intensified so
did the fiery sword that the gate
Guardian swung with ease and finesse
flames burst from the blade the
encroaching fumes Catching Fire along
with the air itself it ignited in a wave
of fire a defensive Inferno that
repelled this latest attack but for a
brief few moments while time stayed slow
before anu's hold on reality inevitably
broke the king had sent forth aif of all
his spawn she was the most reserved
keeping mostly to herself never speaking
she and her children could change their
faces and forms shift into anything or
anyone and walk undetected through the
Multiverse and now her father was
employing her incredible stealth
abilities to slip Behind Enemy Lines
while the gate Guardian was finishing
off the remaining Onslaught from kck's
other daughters it was as aif Drew near
creeping unseen closer and closer to the
entrance keeping the Scarlet King out of
Eden that the guardian seemed to pause
it slowly ominously turned its huge head
tilting until it was looking directly at
at if its expression could be seen maybe
the gate Guardian would almost be
impressed that someone was able to sneak
past it after all was a feat that no
other being in creation could ever hope
to accomplish but then again with its
steadfast conviction and dedication to
its protective Duty maybe it would have
looked upon atiff with anger with the
cleaving swing of its scorching sword
the gate Guardian unfurled a tidal wave
of fire that engulfed everything around
it not just atti but aik aor and adista
all the king's daughters that had
attacked so far along with every one of
their own children were instantly
obliterated they were all reduced to
empty vacant spaces where they had once
been their atoms separated by the
Searing swing of the guardian's weapon
the devastating Blow by his adversary
did little to deter the Scarlet King
from his mission he was still set on
destroying the tree of life and no loss
was too great in his pursuit of
destroying existence he barely cared
that four of his own daughters had just
been unmade by the guardian anit was
still there Clinging On to time as if it
were a thrashing animal the Scarlet King
could simply make her restore her Fallen
and sisters and their forces he had lost
nothing but had held back for too long
and slowly drew his own weapon out of
thin air wielding a sword that was as
blood soaked as the Guardians was hot
the Scarlet King locked blades with the
one being standing in their way both the
ancient Angelic Defender and the
attacking eldrich Abomination were
evenly matched every one of their
viscious strikes against the other met
with an equally strong prry a weapon of
extreme all consuming heat block swipes
from a sharp serrated edge that matched
the Deep Red that would be forever
synonymous with conro the force of their
two swords clashing and striking each
other was so great that it rippled out
from their one-on-one fight the
landscape around them was flattened
wiped clean of any remaining plant life
that hadn't already been destroyed by
the forces of the King's Daughters
despite having acquired nowhere near the
power he would thousands of years after
this fight the Scarlet King was still a
formidable force in single combat and
yet the gate Guardian seemed incapable
of tiring or weakening still standing
strong against the onslaught even after
wiping multiple armies out with its
flaming sword the guardian was still
able to hold its own against the Scarlet
King who was Furious enraged at being so
close to the tree of life yet unable to
get past his Angelic adversary he'd need
to be stronger faster even more ruthless
than the warlord he already was despite
unit's slowing down time the king and
the guardian were at a stalemate time
that was it the Scarlet King needed more
time withdrawing from the fight he
realized that this was a battle that
could not be won by sheer Brute Force
alone his mission to destroy all
creation to get to the tree of life
would take cunning deception and more
time if he let it the gate Guardian
could easily kill con Ro its flaming
weapon could cleave him out of existence
and that would end the king's torment
but it wouldn't be enough a death would
be unsatisfying knowing that the rest of
existence would go on after he was gone
the Scarlet King couldn't accept that it
wasn't enough so he did the one thing
nobody would expect of him he made a
deal with the gate Guardian it was an
action still fueled by his infinite
hatred for all existence his yearning
for total chaos the Scarlet King knew
that one day an event would arrive where
the guardian and the other beings like
it in the Garden of Eden would spill
forth and deliver judgment on this world
and when that Rapture happened the tree
of life would be undefended the Scarlet
King Bartered with the guardian that he
would Retreat for the time being so he
could spend eon's amassing more and more
power then when the fateful day arrived
the gate Guardian would allow him into
Eden to destroy the Tree of Life while
it and its Brethren were busy conducting
the Rapture halting their fight the
Scarlet King offered a crimson claw to
the gate guardian's burning hand
returning to reality from the intense
Vision still feeling sick at what he had
witnessed Robert mon talk looked up at
the still silent form of the gate
Guardian did you do it he yelled
desperate to know more through his
obsession with the Scarlet King did you
tell him yes did you make a deal there
was no answer from the guardian just a
single word that echoed through monto's
fractured
mind if you've ever read the book of
Genesis which is the part of the Old
Testament that details God creating the
world and Humanity during a particularly
busy week then you might just be already
familiar with SCP 001 or at least one of
the anomalies that's been proposed for
the title of SCP 001 because of course
SCP 001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies
contained by the SCP Foundation
anomalies sharing the name SCP 001
include the infamous Scarlet King a
powerful alrich being intent on ending
all of creation that is thought by
Foundation researchers to be one of the
most dangerous beings in this and any
other universe but the Scarlet King
isn't the only incredibly powerful being
categorized as SCP 001 in fact there are
plenty of other anomalies with similar
levels of destructive power and one such
being is a creature codenamed the gate
Guardian standing at well over 1,000 ft
tall the gate Guardian is impossible to
be fully contained by any means that the
foundation possesses the anomaly itself
despite its colossal size is humanoid in
its shape sporting wings that protrude
from its back while it usually has four
of these SCP 001 has historically been
seen to have any number of wings between
2 and 108 sprouting from various places
over its body including its shoulders
ankles wrists and even its temples this
gigantic Guardian also carries its own
weapon referred to as SCP
01-211 rival that of our very own son
for reference the sun has a core
temperature of over 27 million de F and
5,778 kelv at its surface or almost
10,000 de F you would expect a flaming
sword that burns hotter than the sun to
cause a considerable amount of damage
even if it wasn't in use but the Flames
emitted by the weapon leave no lasting
damage on the surrounding environment it
is capable though of annihilating
anything that Strays too close to SCP
001 burning them so intensely that their
atoms literally separate breaking
potential attackers apart on a molecular
level much as its code name suggests the
gate Guardian stands solemnly at the
threshold of some form of dimensional
Gateway which is equally tall as SCP 001
itself behind the guardian is a lush
Grove abundant with fruit trees of
astronomical size as well as other
beings that share a similar appearance
to SCP
001 this Grove is thought to be the
Garden of Eden the paradise that God
created and that was inhabited by Adam
and Eve the first two humans in
existence according to the Book of
Genesis as the tale goes the pair were
created by God himself and permitted to
live in the Garden of Eden as long as
they followed a single rule Adam and Eve
were instructed not to eat any of the
fruit That Grew From certain trees that
God had specified within view just
behind the gate Guardian are two immense
trees one bearing apples and the other
bearing different fruit of an unknown
type the one that looks like an apple
tree is believed even by some in the
foundation to be the biblical tree of
knowledge that Eve was convinced to pick
a fateful Apple from after an encounter
with a snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit is thought to be
the tree of life however this is all
speculation since it is currently
impossible to venture through this
Gateway and verify if the realm Beyond
is truly the Bible's own Garden of Eden
this is largely because anything that
breaches a kilometer wide radius of SCP
001 is instantly vaporized the gate
Guardian attacks with imperceptible
speed using its flaming sword to Smite
any person that gets too close the
guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solemn
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nond to attack ranged attacks
against the guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at SCP 001 reduced two atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
Guardian will be able to sub atomically
vaporize both the projectile itself as
well as the person who sent it
regardless of how far away they are all
while not appearing to lift a finger
during an experiment involving SCP 001
on December 26th 2004 an SCP found
Foundation nuclear submarine called
Nautilus launched a series of multi-
Warhead intercontinental ballistic
missiles at the gate Guardian the
retaliation from the guardian resulted
not only in the deaths of approximately
35,000 innocent civilians but the blast
is also believed by some to have
inadvertently caused the 2004 Boxing Day
tsunami the severity of this incident
came dangerously close to revealing the
foundation's existence to the world
resulting in them rapidly deploying any
means necessary to to erase any trace of
the 35,000 victims families friends and
other related individuals in order to
avoid questioning the SCP Foundation
administered amnestics on an almost
worldwide scale and the 05 Council
banned any further tests on SCP 001 that
involved nuclear weapons in what was
hoped by the foundation to be a test
with lower Stakes they sent an
Expendable d-class Personnel towards SCP
001 the d-class approached the area
where the gate Guardian is located and
as soon as they saw it they could hear a
very clear command in their mind leave
the d-class Personnel reacted exactly
the same way you or I would they
promptly turned and started to walk away
they didn't need a th000 foot tall
entity with a flaming sword to tell them
twice the researchers running the
experiment were not swayed by the
request and ordered the declass to
continue moving towards SCP 001 when the
d-class continued to ignore their
commands they were terminated as his
standard policy when dealing with an
insubordinate member of d-class SCP 001
appeared not to like this for some
reason though and the researcher site as
well as the researchers themselves were
immediately obliterated by an unknown
Force though it's a pretty safe guess
that a certain flaming weapon was
responsible this candidate for scp1 may
be one of if not the most powerful being
that the SCP Foundation has ever in
encountered and according to its entry
in the SCP 001 file the guardian is even
responsible for the creation of the
foundation itself if the file is to be
believed the administrator of the SCP
Foundation One Day heard a word echoing
through his head
prepare this one-word instruction led
him to starting the SCP Foundation
containing countless dangerous anomalies
and entities in preparation for an
uncertain future in all that time since
the very beginning of the foundation the
gate Guardian has remained standing at
its post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards Humanity the gate
Guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at least as individuals it
rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked and venturing too close
to the guardian however is not an
automatic death sentence the guardian
first communicates with any living being
approaching it via a telepathic message
instructing them to either leave or
forget if whomever has stepped too close
to SCP 001 complies with the
instructions they'll be able to freely
leave the area while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of the gate
guardian's existence ignore These
Warnings though and SCP 001 has no
qualms about completely eliminating you
from reality given its enormous
destructive potential it is no wonder
that the foundation has tried to use the
gate Guardian to eliminate other
dangerous SCP each with varying results
the foundation at one time even
attempted to use the gate Guardian to
destroy the infamously indestructible
SCP 682 better known by the appropriate
name of the hardto destroy reptile due
to the malicious contempt SCP 682 holds
for human beings and all other forms of
life it is perhaps one of the most
dangerous anomalies the SCP Foundation
has in containment SCP 682 is also one
of the few creatures the foundation ly
wants to terminate a task made that much
harder given that 682 can regenerate its
entire form from as little as a single
cell the gate Guardian had already shown
time and time again that it was capable
of massive destruction and researchers
working for the foundation HED to
harness that power to rid the world of
SCP 682 for good 682 was placed on an
unmanned vehicle and carried to within 1
km of the gate Guardian the guardian
attacked the vehicle seriously wounding
but not killing 682 it seemed even the
mighty SCP 001 couldn't kill the hardto
destroy reptile while the researchers
were disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the guardian 682
mentioned that the gate Guardian is not
uel but a pretender uel is the Archangel
that some religious texts describe as
the guardian standing at the Gate of
Eden with a fiery sword so does this
mean that 682 knows that the gate
Guardian is not actually an angel or
that the location it is guarding isn't
the Garden of Eden at all any truth or
meaning behind these comments has as of
yet been undetermined by the SCP
Foundation a later experiment involved
both SCP 001 and SCP 073 the anomaly
otherwise known as Cain Cain is a male
humanoid of possible Arabic descent
whose arms legs spine and shoulders are
replaced in an almost cyborg like
fashion with brillium br bronze much
like the gate Guardian SCP 073 may also
be the same as the one mentioned in the
Bible's Book of Genesis who according to
the biblical story murdered his own
brother Abel out of spite as punishment
for his actions Cain was cursed to
eternally suffer for his wrongdoing in
the case of SCP 073 any damage inflicted
on him is deflected back to the attacker
but Cain is made to feel the pain of the
attack any plants or plant-based matter
Withers and rots in his presence and he
is cursed with a perfect memory keeping
him forever haunted by his murder of AEL
when C was brought before the gate
Guardian an unknown incident occurred
the foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
Kane's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on SCP
001 the encounter left SCP 073
unconscious and even permanently blinded
nearby research Personnel it was as a
direct result of this incident that the
05 Council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be
conducted on SCP 001 with the
administrator even filing an executive
order that no scps be exposed to the
guardian and that SCP 001 was to never
be used for the attempted termination of
other
scps of course perhaps it wasn't just
the mistakes of the past that made the
council decide that SCP 001 was best
left alone at some point an erratic
transmission was received from site Zero
by Foundation Personnel detailing an XK
Class end of the world scenario in the
transmission the sender believed to be
another member of the SCP Foundation
described an event during which the gate
Guardian finally left its post stepping
away from the entrance to the Garden of
Eden SCP 001 has left its location the
cender wrote the gate is open they are
riding forth oh God it's so beautiful
the transmission then goes on to repeat
various phrases including the Lord shall
reign forever and here o Israel the Lord
Our God the Lord is one what can be
inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the
end of the world some believe that once
God deems it time his Angelic armies
will lay waste to the Earth in order to
remake it as a paradise when this occurs
as cp01 the gate Guardian will open the
gate he stands in front of allowing the
other beings like it to emerge into our
world ready to cleanse it perhaps most
interesting is the source of the message
the transmission was received from
within the foundation from site zero
however when questioned by Personnel
05-14 told them that no such message had
been sent or even existed while some
disregarded the transmission telling of
the end of the world as a hoax it was
then that a time stamp was discovered
this warning had not been sent from site
zero at least not yet and was dated
several years in the future despite this
ominous warning of things to come the
gate Guardian remains inactive standing
at the threshold to Eden waiting the
desert is still the night seems endless
silent and at peace until it's pierced
by the sound of gunshots and
screams deep in the Sahara the sccp
foundation is Waging War against a newly
discovered enemy a squad of foundation
agents is ret treating trying to get
away from the ones who massacred their
allies they were attempting to eliminate
the threat using conventional means but
their rifles were no match for the
reality bending entities of the kingdom
of abdon the retreating agents cover one
another as they make their way back to
the extraction point the enemy Force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the Sorcerers of abdon
disintegrate Into Thin Air this is not
an enemy they can defeat the SCP agents
need to get back to base and and relay
what they have found to their
superiors out of the hundreds of Agents
sent into the Sahara that night only a
handful make it out alive they are
debriefed by their superiors at the
foundation who classifi the anomalous
humanoids under the highest of threat
levels the kingdom of abdon is a threat
the kingdom of abdon must be eliminated
reconnaissance done prior to the
disastrous Mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the abdon humanoids were
responsible for the deaths of no fewer
than 75 Foundation personnel and had
stolen at least 12 different items from
the foundation the leaders of the SCP
Foundation tasked research team Omega 5
with developing a weapon that would be
capable of destroying the kingdom of
abdon once and for all the weapon they
are researching must be capable of long
range destruction because the moment any
foundation agent gets close to the area
there are vaporized by the reality
manipulating powers of its inhabitants
the project is given the name twins of
God and is led by a foundation doctor
known only by the designation
051 051 is popular in the SCP Foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
charismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and 051 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for to
defeat the kingdom of abdon item
01 and so the Omega 5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible Powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item o1 entity
and set up a series of experiments using
different people to harness its energy
the first series of tests all end in
tragedy the anomaly causes the entity it
inhabits to become intensely radioactive
anyone who gets close to it succumbs to
immediate radiation sickness and
eventually death to stop the radiation
problem the Omega 5 research group
intensifies the containment procedures
051 receives reports from the higher-ups
that the kingdom of abdon has attacked
another Foundation facility in Sudan
long range defense is needed ASAP the
administrator puts more pressure on
Omega 5 and especially its leader 051 to
solve the problems of item o1 and
develop a weapon that can save the
foundation he stays awake for days on
end working tirelessly to create a safe
and controllable item 001 entity
although there are signs that the weapon
will work it is still unpredictable when
item 001 is initiated the host entity
becomes paralyzed suffers severe
cerebral hren and soon a new host is
needed before testing Can Begin Again
and that's not the only thing that goes
wrong whenever the anomaly is put into a
new host sudden and random destruction
of on-site structures and Personnel take
place 051 knows though that if this
power can be harnessed and controlled in
the right way that it could be the
weapon that the foundation needs to wipe
out the kingdom of abidon once and for
all in order to control item o1 051 has
a mind kill switch implanted in its
host's brains 051 can activate the
implant to incapacitate its host and
immediately Stop The Unwanted
destruction countless hosts are
terminated by this mind kill switch in
the early trials conducted by the Omega
5 team but progress continues to be made
and eventually a hypothesis is
formulated perhaps the dis ous side
effects of item o1 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power but 051 and the Omega 5
team need more data and for that they
need more bodies they consult with the
director of site 17 and it is concluded
that the nearby town of San Marco would
be an appropriate place to get the the
additional test subjects they require on
a quiet Sunday morning Omega 5 along
with support from a squad of armed SCP
agents Storm Into the San Marcos de la
Vias thna Church during the middle of
mass they gather up a number of the
younger congregants and bring them back
to the site where item 01 is housed the
researchers quickly ran through their
new supply of test subjects though and
Omega 5 would need to get even more if
their research was to continue instead
of going back and forth between the
testing facility and S Marcos 051
decided to move the entire item o1
operation to the town itself he renames
the town testing
site1 and Omega 5 rounds up 23 of the
healthiest subjects they can find for
use in the next series of research tests
a few weeks after occupying the town of
San Marco Omega 5 makes its most
substantial progress yet just as they
theorized by spreading out the anomaly
of item 01 across a specific group of
hosts they can control its powers the
test may have cost the lives of almost
everyone in the town but the ends
certainly justify the means the kingdom
of abdon poses an existential threat to
the SCP Foundation after all and thanks
to This research they will soon have a
weapon capable of bringing them Victory
the foundation administer criticize 0
51's methods but can't argue with his
results unfortunately 051 has a dark
secret a secret that disturbs even the
most hardened and loyal members of Omega
5 a secret that has to do with the item
01 hosts the host that Omega 5 has made
its major progress with are not the
ordinary test subjects normally used by
the foundation no the test subjects 051
makes his breakthrough with are children
nine of them to be exact all between 4
and 11 years old despite being told
specifically by the foundation
administrator to only test on adults the
research required 051 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down
the path it led the children are
contained in a reinforced bunker where
only 051 and a select few have access
they are technically alive but are
functionally brain dead the group of
nine children share a hive mine that can
process information and more importantly
can unleash the full potential of the
implanted anomaly creating and
controlling a devastating power but not
everyone is thrilled with what they've
achieved members of Omega 5 are haunted
by the screen dream of the children that
they forc to be part of their weapons
development program they describe their
merging with item o1 as being a process
that rips out their souls and replaces
them with something much more Sinister
in fact all of Omega 5 regret what they
have been a part of and what they've
done all except
051 the nine children can Channel
unprecedented amounts of energy from an
unknown origin that Omega 5 hypothesizes
comes from an extradimensional source
which is then used to unbind atoms at
the quantum level when the right
activation words are spoken it appears
as though this tremendous power gives
the children the ability to annihilate
anything in the entire universe it's a
gun to end all guns and only 051 has the
key to control it the nine children work
so well with an item o1 that Omega 5
reclassifies it to include the nine
children themselves they are not just
the entity housing more controlling item
o1 they permanently become item
o1 once Omega 5 has a better
understanding of item o1 they begin to
run tests to find out the full extent of
its abilities first they test the
distance item o1 can reach the initial
test that Omega 5 carries out is on a
steel rod placed 5 km away 051 orders
the children to destroy the target
moments later the phone next to 051
begins to ring when he picks it up the
Observer tased with watching the pole is
on the other end he informs 051 that the
steel rod has been completely vaporized
051 is not satisfied though he has
another pole sent out this time placed
8,000 km away from the nine children 051
asked the children to destroy that Rod
almost immediately the phone rings again
the target has been vaporized 051 Smiles
the next series of test Omega 5 runs on
item 01 are to determine the maximum
size of an object that can be destroyed
the test start out with a steel sphere 3
m in diameter placed 1,000 km from item
01 051 orders the children to destroy
the object it is instantly vaporized 051
has seen enough small tests it's time
for something big so he does something
that will later be questioned by
everyone at the SCP Foundation he orders
the nine children to destroy a church of
the broken God worship site in Turkey
not long after the destruction order is
given to item o1 reports begin coming in
the worship site has been obliterated
with no observable damage to the
surrounding area deadly and precise 051
closes his eyes and takes a deep breath
he looks as if he's overcome by an
immense spiritual experience he opens
his eyes leans over to the children and
Whispers the name of someone later that
day 051 finds out that the target he had
named has been vaporized the success of
Omega 5 in item 00 1 is relayed to the
administration of the foundation they
are so impressed that they make plans to
use item 001 to eliminate the abidon
threat once and for all however one of
the heads of the foundation
administrator Williams has major
concerns about the way 051 is running
the program the updates that 051 has
been sending have become less scientific
and more
philosophical more spiritual
administrator Williams sends a letter
to5 1 reassuring him that he is doing
good work but once the mission to
destroy the kingdom of abdon is
completed 051 will be promoted to
director and reassigned to the newly
constructed site 19 for the good of the
foundation and maybe the rest of the
world he'll be permanently moved away
from item
001 0 51's response is short and to the
point I am fine administrator the
project is finished we will complete our
task when you arrive administrator
Williams arrives at site 001 a few days
later he is greeted by 051 and the Omega
5 team Williams can't help but notice
that 051 has a strange look in his eyes
it is the look of a crazy man who has
been lost in his work and who has
perhaps lost himself Williams puts the
thought away though and walks with 051
and his accompanying agents to the
viewing area where the powers of item
001 will be
demonstrated administrator Williams and
the other agents watch from a protected
viewing room as 051 enters the Chamber
of his new super weapon it's time to see
if their weapon that has had so much
time effort sweat tears and especially
blood poured into it will have been
worth it everyone watches as 051 leans
over and says the name of the abdon
Citadel to the nine children all at once
they start to Glow no one observing can
see what has happened in the far off
Kingdom but they know something big has
happened the administr is thrilled but
notices something 051 hesitated a moment
while leaning over the children before
standing back up did he whisper
something else to them and then
administrator Williams vaporizes pulled
apart at an atomic level before he has
the chance to scream what's going on the
agents standing next to where
administrator Williams previously
existed begin to yell and pull out their
guns they burst through the door of the
observation room and run down the
hallway towards where 051 and the nine
children are located the arm agents rush
into the room but 051 is gone nine
children are still over the next few
weeks 051 is reported to be seen several
times by SCP agents however no one is
able to catch him and it appears as
though other members of the SCP
Foundation have also gone awall as well
perhaps joining him on the run it is
unclear what his plan is but the reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into
the Sahara make it obvious what the
result of his first command to the
children was there is an a single
humanoid or building left in the Kingdom
of abdon but even with this Victory the
highest levels of the SCP Foundation
have an ominous thought lurking in the
back of their minds where did 051 go and
what is he planning to do next following
the improper use of item 01 leading to
the untimely death of a high ranking
Foundation staff member the weapon was
deemed too dangerous and containment
procedures were implemented due to the
high amount of radiation they were found
to admit the nine children children were
placed into leadline bags and buried
under 50 m of concrete beneath the
Church of St Marcos de La Via
Eterna though all of the children
continued to be functionally brain dead
they still display Signs of Life despite
their containment and by order of the
overseer Council have been classified as
a Thal entity the smell of fire and oil
fills the air the sound of gears
grinding can be heard between the
explosions and shrieks of Terror a man
runs out of his house only to have his
leg grabbed by a metal arm and dragged
back through his front door SCP 001
leaves a trail of metal fragments and
mechanical Parts on the ground in the
wake of its destruction iron chains
swing from its form cast iron gears
whirl within it a glowing light throbs
from the center of its body SCP 001 is
consuming everything in its path after
incorporating the truck chassis into its
being as CP 001 rolls in a lumbering
fashion to the next house it rips the
gutters from the side of the building
residents who live in the area flee
their neighborhood all the while hoping
that the mechanical monstrosity skips
over their house so they have something
to return to if they make it out alive a
section of SCP 001's undercarriage drops
away from the main body it rolls down
the street consuming more and more
material the new entity resembles a
human spine in rib cage it topples over
unable to support itself the ri likee
formations extend out to grab anything
and everything within reach the newly
Incorporated material forms what can
only be described as a head light from
within the eye sockets fixate on nearby
civilians the metallic creature picks up
the people and places them inside its
exposed steel rib cage then it turns and
spots a woman helplessly trying to crawl
away the creature reaches out with a
spiked tentacle and wraps it around the
woman's body she is placed inside side
of the chest cavity moments later a
severed hand falls out of the entity and
onto the ground the mechanical monster
continues to gather bodies and materials
incorporating them into its frame a
growth begins to slowly expand on its
back it becomes so massive that the
creature Falls over and uses its limbs
to Scurry to a nearby house there is a
sickening crunching sound as the growth
bursts from within emerges three
humanoid creatures resembling the
civilians that the entity had consumed
earlier a female with chains extending
from her scalp like dreadlocks stumbles
away the second humanoid is a man with
cogs for limbs he examines the
clock-like components that have been
incorporated into his body then stares
blankly into the distance the third
humanoid lies motionless on the ground
he did not make it the two functioning
humanoids look at their creator intently
for a moment nothing moves then as if
they have been given orders
telepathically the half human half
machine humanoids turn and run away from
the Mayhem a few weeks before the
massacre caused by what would be
designated as SCP 001 the foundation had
been in contact with the Allied ult
initiative there were rumors of an
anomalous object in Mexico being
worshiped by a group of people who
identified themselves as the Church of
the broken God Intel about the church
claimed their deity was a small
mechanical box filled with cogs and
pistons the Box supposedly had
supernatural abilities it was said to be
able to communicate with congregants of
the Church of the broken God
telepathically The Devout worship the
Box following any order it gave and in
return they were filled with an emotion
that could be only described as Divine
as World War II rages on in Europe the
foundation sends agents to recover
anomalies in Mexico that might help with
the war effort while there the
foundation force is tasked with learning
about the Church of the broken God they
are also ordered to investigate a town
near laaz where there are troubling
accounts of a mechanical anomalous
creature causing Mayhem the agents make
their way through Mexico Gathering
various objects to bring back to
Foundation sites in the United States
the unit loads all of the anomalies they
were covered onto a train with a plan to
check out the stories of the mechanical
anomaly they've heard about as they make
their way to the US border the train
heads North along rusted rails just
outside laaz they've come across a
broken down train filled with what looks
to be refugees when the foundation unit
goes to investigate they find all of the
refugees repeating the the same words
over and over again but they don't
understand the foundation agents look at
one another confused until one of them
translates the words into English the
words the refugees are saying over and
over again are La makina the machine the
commanding officer orders a squad of
foundation agents to proceed up the
tracks to see if they can figure out
what has the refugees so scared they
make their way towards laaz disappearing
Over the Horizon as the sun sets the
remaining Foundation agents hear
gunshots in the distance they stay awake
all night remaining Vigilant waiting for
the exploratory Squad but morning comes
without anyone returning 3 days later
the foundation Force still has not seen
anything since the exploratory Squad
left then as the sun sits lazily in the
morning Sky a lone figure is spotted
walking down the tracks towards the
trains one of the agents on watch blows
his whistle and points to the figure a
squad of Agents rushes towards the
shadow of a man their guns are raised
ready for anything the figure drops to
the ground and begins to crawl along the
tracks the agents reach the Fallen man
only to find that he is one of their
squadmates who has been sent up the
tracks to investigate laaz several days
before the agent's name is DeMarco he is
covered in blood his clothes are in
tatters and he has lost a boot DeMarco
lies on his back with Foundation agents
standing around him his eyes are wide
and wild he keeps babbling on about a
world eater how the rest of his Squad
had been Mol
and he is the only one who made it out
alive the foundation agents carry
DeMarco back to the makeshift base they
created by the trains they need to
figure out a way to get the Convoy
moving again but whatever is up ahead
has already taken out an entire
Foundation Squad it had to be something
anomalous but what could it possibly be
the unit of foundation agents prepare to
move towards laaz they start loading
their rifles and check the amount of
ammunition and explosives available in
case the containment process gets out of
hand just as they are about to leave the
base a convoy appears on the horizon it
is an Allied occult initiative Force
preparing to attack whatever it is that
is devastating leas this organization's
mission is to not secure contain or
protect but to destroy the foundation
may be in over their heads on this one
and the Joint Force with the Allied oult
initiative may be the only way to stop
what is now known as SCP 001 the aoi and
Foundation Force gears up for battle
they set out for laaz and what they find
spine causes them to Quake with fear SCP
001 has consumed so much material it is
the size of a mountain it moves like a
tidal wave of mechanical destruction
washing over the buildings and Landscape
under it whatever SCP 001 passes over is
consumed and added to its massive body
SCP 001 started as a small mechanical
box with cogs but now has morphed into a
gigantic metal death machine the Church
of the broken God has finally met their
maker as the small entity they once
worshiped has now consumed all of its
members their God is an allc consuming
monster the aoi and Foundation forces do
everything they can to stop SCP 00001
from continuing its reign of Destruction
they fire barrage after barrage of
bullets and explosives into the
mechanical anomaly they bring in air
support to try and damage it from the
skies but nothing works the aoi uses an
artifact in their possession to lure SCP
001 to the coast of the Pacific Ocean
where a trap has been set for the
so-called God the Monstrous mechanical
creature moves slowly towards the water
it consumes abandoned cars buildings and
boats as it approaches the coastline it
even shovels large amounts of Earth into
its form causing Flames to spurt out
from its inner workings smoke Bellows
from openings between different
mechanical components like a volcano
before it is about to erupt suddenly
seemingly from nowhere a massive cloud
with a reddish tint appears in the sky
Air Raid Sirens can be heard in the
distance the enormous Cloud begins to
pulsate streaks of lightning shoot
through the Red Mist in the sky it now
sits directly over SCP 001 from within
the cloud part of a ship can be seen it
appears to be slightly damaged
electricity flows over its hole the
vessel in the giant Red Cloud is
classified ASP
2399 the underside of the vessel begins
to Glow aqua blue a blind in beam of
light is ejected from SCP 2399 which
penetrates straight down and through SCP
001 for a moment everything is still
there is complete silence then as if SCP
001 is trying to reach up and grab the
vessel above it a mechanical bulge
reaches out before SCP 001 can grab the
vessel above there is another bright
flash of light SCP 2399 blinks out of
existence the sound of grinding gears
can be heard coming from within SCP 001
it begins to shed its outer layers of
metal then the entire structure that was
SCP 001 collapses into the water and
onto the beach giant cogs fall from the
sky parts of vehicles embed themselves
in the sand as the foundation and aoi
agents approach the piles of scrap metal
and mechanical components they see that
some of them are still moving it is as
if an invisible power source is still
pulsating through some of the Machinery
the Agents of of the foundations
celebrate the destruction of the giant
mechanical beast but little do they know
this was only a piece of the entity
worshiped as the broken God the
foundation agents collect as many of the
still moving Parts as they can they find
spinning gears twitching pulleys and
firing Pistons as the parts are
separated from one another and carried
away from the main wreckage of SCP 001
they slowly stop moving and become
inactive some of the artifacts were
covered were identified as being
connected to the Church of the broken
God these facts are found closer to the
middle of what was once a mountain-sized
SCP 001 hundreds of anomalous artifacts
are collected and transported to SCP
Foundation sites collecting the broken
parts of SCP 001 is relatively safe
however some agents get too close to the
larger moving Parts getting caught in
them and losing a body part or two but
most agents proceed with caution and
survive the collection ordeal with their
arms and legs still attached to their
bodies dive teams are sent into the
water to recover parts s that have sunk
to the Bottom of the Sea one of the
divers is a local from the area he is
hired to bring up the heart of the
machine since he is an experienced diver
used to free diving to Great depths to
collect oysters from the bottom of the
bay the diver enters the water and swims
down into the murky depths he secures
straps around the heart of SCP 001 and
pulls hard on the Rope as an indication
to the surface that it is ready to be
hauled up the Salvage team on the
surface begins to pull there is a second
slight tug on the Rope then it goes
slack the team continues to pull when
they get the heart to the surface they
are horrified at what else comes up with
it tangled in the ropes is the lifeless
body of the diver his head is smashed
between two moving pieces of the heart
it looks as if he shoved his head
between the slabs of metal himself the
Salvage team untangles the Body Rolls it
off the deck and back into the ocean the
mechanical box which was the heart of
SCP 001 is offloaded on the shore but as
as the foundation prepares to move it to
a containment facility the weather
starts to deteriorate hurricane force
wind sweeps across the water and batter
the coast the heart is kept in a secured
storage Warehouse until it can be moved
the people living in the village nearby
complain of hearing voices and rashes so
itchy that they practically tear their
skin off once the storm passes the
foundation agents load the heart onto a
ship it is to be transported to a
foundation site just across the border
the ocean seems calm and Serene the
foundation ship UND and begins its
Journey up the coast not too long after
beginning its Journey the ship slowly
drifts off course it is as if the crew
has stopped Manning their posts and the
ship is being controlled by a mind of
its own the foundation ship crashes and
sinks somewhere in the Pacific Ocean
never to be found and most importantly
the heart of SCP 001 doesn't make it to
the foundation site years later a man is
walking along the beach he hears
something it sounds like someone
pounding on a large drum to the rhythm
of a heartbeat the man walks towards the
sound something is drawing him forward
closer and closer to the heartbeat he
walks and walks until the beating stops
he bends down and moves the sand aside
he spots the corner of a mechanical box
sticking out of the white sand the man
digs deeper and pulls out the small box
inside he can see gears whirling and
pistons firing he holds the Box close to
his own heart it seems to speak to him
the man brings the box back to town he
starts to worship the box and soon more
and more people in the area join the new
religion they cast aside their own
beliefs and focus on the powerful entity
contained within the Box God is not dead
at least not yet but the Prophecies of
the Church of the broken God say that
when the heart is found the God will
reassemble itself once again then The
Unbroken God will destroy all other
false deities until only he remains it's
a quiet evening at Area 11 where the
Petri Cal Fane spatial stabilization
array is housed a skeleton crew is
working overnight to ensure the array is
ready for its big test the following day
the foundation has been working on a
particle accelerator that will contain
anomalies with the ability to manipulate
the nature of SpaceTime the preliminary
tests seemed promising but a few last
minute tweaks to the array are necessary
unfortunately it is on this night in 198
2 that marks the beginning of the end
for the SCP Foundation Dr Calvin Desman
is monitoring the array and he notices
as it spools up that there are some
minor power fluctuation in one of the
stabilization arms this problem is not
uncommon due to the vast amounts of
energy being pumped through the array
and the harmonic resonance the machine
gives off which slowly causes the
coupling rings to loosen Calvin desmid
decides that remounting the
stabilization Rings will be an easy fix
and it's a NE Neary one he knows that if
the Rings fail during the actual test
the array could end up shut down for
months there is still plenty of time so
Kelvin Desmond grabs his toolbox and
heads down to the array the machine is
still spooling keeping the energy
flowing at a constant low rate there is
no danger at the moment as the inside of
the array is shielded from the radiation
and energy pulsing through the outer
ring but then something unexpected
happens the system's primary generator
begins to fluctuate uncontrolled
a catastrophic failure is imminent
Sirens begin to sound the facility is
evacuated and the Chamber is sealed deep
in the bowels of the array Calvin desmid
cannot hear the evacuation announcement
the humming of the array Echoes through
the chamber dampening all sound from the
outside world the array begins to come
online while desmid continues to work on
the coupling he has no idea what is
about to happen meanwhile a team of
foundation scientists scrambled to get
the power fluctuations in the main
generator under control as they
frantically work catastrophe strikes
they initiate the power down cycle but
as the generator struggles to keep the
power flow balanced an energy surge
builds up a massive amount of energy is
released all at once causing the main
reactor to explode the entire structure
rocks back and forth and Desmond is
thrown into the side of the array he too
now knows that something is very wrong
and runs for the exit when he reaches
the door he finds that it has been
sealed in a panic Desmond continues
running through the tube to the next
access point this door has been locked
as well he's never been so scared in his
entire life and he shakes uncontrollably
from the adrenaline being dumped into
his muscles The Surge of energy rushes
through the array towards Desmet a
singularity begins to form in the
containment chamber the array is working
just as it should except that there was
never supposed to be a person inside as
the singularity was brought into
existence moments after after the
singularity forms the massive pole of
its gravity causes the stabilizer arm
that Desmond had been working on to fail
the side of the array is ripped off and
Calvin Desmet stares into the naked eye
of the singularity everything is silent
and still for a moment then the
singularity collapses in on itself
taking the test chamber and much of the
research wing with it along with Dr
Calvin desmi sparking wires hang from
the exposed walls and ceiling where the
singularity RI the main structure away
water flows into the deep hole carved
out of the Earth where the array once
stood the scientists from Area 11 look
into the crater left by the collapse
Singularity the foundation
Administration sends agents to collect
the staff at the site and document the
failings of the project they conclude
that the accident was caused by human
error they ordered the array to be
rebuilt this time using entirely
automated systems to eliminate the
chances of another mishap occurring
several years after the catastrophic
events at Area 11 a new array is
constructed an intelligent system called
netac is put in charge of overseeing its
functions it is a supercomputer that is
programmed to follow commands but can
autonomously make decisions in order to
prevent any failures in the system
experiments Begin Again in May of 2006
the new array soon manifests its first
singularity in the containment chamber
at Area 11 and what happens next will
forever change the foundation and the
Multiverse the Singularity is kept
stable in the array it seems as if the
foundation has succeeded in trapping and
containing spatial anomalies but as they
run more Diagnostics on the anomaly
something unexpected happens The
Singularity begins to grow in size the
point of infinite gravity threatens to
breach containment as it reaches the
boundaries of the array just before
contact the singularity's growth slows
and then stops netac has made the
split-second calculations and
adjustments necessary to contain the s
Singularity the artificial intelligence
has saved the facility and the lives of
everyone in it now sitting in the array
is a thick rotating cloud of radioactive
gas and dust obscuring the singularity
within as Foundation scientists work
rapidly to fix the array odd events
begin to occur the workers hear noises
that sound like painful wailing over
time the noises evolve into words and
then full sentences they seem to be
originating from The Singularity using a
equipment able to penetrate the thick
cloud of radioactive gas the foundation
scientists get a glimpse at the
singularity to their surprise The
Singularity has taken on the shape of a
human the scientists work frantically to
figure out how the singularity could
have formed itself into a humanoid shape
Dr J Barton Ramsay is the first to try
and make contact with the humanoid
within the singularity he finds that the
entity cannot communicate in the
traditional sense the massive
gravitational pole of the singularity
does not allow sound to escape its void
Instead The Entity manipulates gravity
to vibrate the suspension rings of the
array itself and create sound waves the
being in the singularity Whispers in a
metallic voice created by the vibrating
of the arrays rings and says yanes
Ramsey Dr Ramsey steps back from the
observation window how do you know my
name he asked the entity the humanoid
within the swirling gas cloud identifies
itself as having the memories of Calvin
Desmond it is not desmit per se the
being in the singularity is so much more
than one person but it was somehow
created by the accident that had suck
Calvin Desmond into the singularity
years before the entity seems to switch
between the mind of desmat and the vast
Infinity of the cosmos The desmit Entity
asks for an overseer from the foundation
to be brought in it has a proposal for
the 05 Council when Dr Ramsey asks why
the entity needs to talk to the
overseers it replies that it wants to
offer them a way out the following day
051 enters the facility and heads to the
observation deck he looks through the
reinforced glass at the swirling cloud
of radioactive dust then glances at the
monitor to see the humanoid shape of the
singularity within he presses the
microphone button on the console and
addresses The Entity to whom am I
speaking he asks for Simplicity say The
Entity tells 0 5-1 to refer to him as
Calvin Desmond 05 D1 makes notes of the
events unfolding before him and then
asks about the way out that Calvin had
mentioned the air is still for a moment
then Desmond begins to speak through the
vibration of the structure once again he
informs 0 5-1 that what the SCP
Foundation is doing by securing and
containing anomalous entities around the
world is like putting a small Band-Aid
on a much bigger wound Desmond wants to
propose a final solution to all of the
foundation's problems 0 5-1 listens
intently as the entity unravels the
mysteries of where the scps have come
from he explains that the anomalies that
the foundation has works so hard to
secure contain and protect the human
race from are actually bleeding into
their reality from a vast Multiverse the
only way to stop the manifestation of
anomalies into this universe is to
destroy all other realities The Entity
that is Calvin Desmond tells 05- one
that he is able to bring about this
destruction if they release him from the
confines of the array 0 5-1 is
transfixed by the swirling gas that is
promising him and everyone else on Earth
salvation he shakes his head in
disbelief could this be true 0 5-1 turns
away from the swirling gas and begins to
walk away from the viewing glass I'll
need to think about what you're saying
the structure begins to shake slightly
the voice of Calvin Desmond reverberates
off of the array a little louder than
before choose quickly overseer although
it won't happen for decades eventually a
catastrophic SCP event will wipe out
life on this planet perhaps not in your
lifetime but it will most certainly
happen within the lifetime of your
children we will talk again soon the
vibrations slow and then stop completely
there is an eerie Stillness in the
observation room as
051a members located at Area 11 are re
located to other Foundation sites and
given amnestics the 05 Council meets in
a large circular room with wood paneling
and no windows 0 5-1 Begins the meeting
by telling the others what Calvin
Desmond had described about the end of
the world he pauses for what seems like
an eternity and tells them of Desmond's
offer that he could prevent the end of
the world but at the cost of destroying
an infinite number of other realities
this would mean that all the humans and
creatures of those realities would be
destroyed destroyed as well was
murdering countless other beings worth
it to protect their own reality 0 5-1
begins to shake he hasn't slapped or
eaten anything since his talk with
Desmond he's being torn apart from the
inside 0 5-3 stands up and addresses the
council he informs everyone in the room
that independent teams have concluded
Research into what the Calvin Desmond
entity has claimed and they found it to
be true the world really would come to
an end furthermore the research teams
determined that the capabilities of
Desmond would in fact allow him to
dismantle the other realities 0 5-3
insists that the council must vote to
allow Desmond to destroy the other
realities to ensure that this reality
could be saved they must strike now
before the world is overrun 0 5-1
continues to Shake while 0 5-3 breathes
heavily sweat pouring down his temples
the rest of the council shifts their
gazes from side to side it is time for a
vote there are eight eyes to allow
Desmond to destroy all of realities and
four Nays against the plan 0 5-3 stands
up and walks around the room stopping
behind each nay voter and putting a
bullet in their head he stops at the
last 05- 9 who pulls out a gun places it
under her own chin and pulls the trigger
05-13 abstains from the vote and the
measure passes the remaining overseers
will use the Calvin Desmond entity to
save the reality at the expense of all
others and they soon head to Area 11 to
execute their plan
05-14 and 12 enter the observation room
that looks upon the swirling radioactive
gas around Calvin Desmond 0 5-1 orders
netac to begin powering down the array
which will allow the entity to prove he
can do what he has promised they have
pinpointed the reality that SCP 884 came
from and the Shaving mirror itself sits
on a table in another room in the
facility 0 5-3 stands in the room
watching the mirror to see if anything
happens 0 5-1 asks Calvin Desmond to
eliminate the reality that the mirror
had come from the room Shakes as the
entity uses it to acknowledge the
request moments later the phone rings in
the observation room it is
[Music]
0 5-1 asks Calvin Desmond to continue
and destroy all the realities that are
bleeding into their own this time the
entire facility begins to Quake suddenly
0 5-1 jerks backwards his eyes wide in
confusion and horror his body seems to
be compressing under an unknown Force 0
5-1 begins to distort his legs and arms
fold into the core of his body his head
snaps down and all that was 05- one is
sucked down into a single point in space
before it completely disappears Calvin
Desmond then turns his attention to the
other two overseers in the room who both
seem to collapse into black holes of
their own in the center of their bodies
net Zac's warning claxson begins to
sound signaling that the emergency fail
safe has been activated before Calvin
Desmond is brought under control the
structural support in the entire
facility vibrates with his words they
are in a voice that sounds strangely
similar to 0 51's your children are free
to live life lives that do not end in
horror an end to your Perpetual struggle
an end to Darkness the freedom to live
in the light all traces must be removed
this world must be washed clean the
foundation does not Escape atonement it
is the only way out it had been a
deception the Calvin Desmond entity had
no intention of stopping anomalies from
infiltrating this world it wanted to
remove all traces of the anomalous from
all universes including this one and
that meant destroying the overseers and
the foundation itself their destruction
would serve as an atonement for the pain
and suffering they had caused in their
quest to secure and contain the
anomalous Calvin had to lie to the
overseers about the real plan since he
knew they'd never sacrificed themselves
and the foundation even if it meant an
end to the anomalies plaguing our world
now though with the overseers out of the
way the Calvin Desmond entity is free to
move forward with its plan and Purge all
realities of any trace of the anomalous
but just then net saac fail safes kick
in and the Petra Cal fan spatial
stabilization array subdues the entity's
abilities desmit is once again contained
0 5-3 burst through the door and into
the observation room he stands before
the shattered glass of the window that
looks into the array 053 ask asks net
saac how long the containment array can
hold Calvin desmit the computer's voice
fades in and out but says given current
conditions
119 days 6 hours and 47 minutes 0 5-3
size he tells net Zac to make a node in
the SCP database that the Calvin desmit
entity will now be known as
scp1 then to make dozens of other
randomly generated entries and label
them as SCP 1 as well he knows that they
will need to keep the true nature of
what this entity can do a secret 0 5-3
walks out of the room under his breath
he speaks to himself they'll say that
I'll know the one true God when I see it
and to give that God everything at wants
because that's the only thing that
matters tonight it appears God wants to
talk to me Calvin Lucien stands at the
end of a Dusty table in an abandoned
warehouse in the shadows across from him
sit several hidden figures the warehouse
is falling apart but is suitable for the
meeting Calvin has requested with the
heads of the chaos Insurgency he has
completed numerous missions for the
organization and each one has been
successful now he is proposing one final
mission Calvin Lucian takes a tattered
Journal out of his bag and slides it
across the table to the figures sitting
in the shadows it's a journal with
details on the habits of each of the 13
Foundation overseers he says there is
silent from the other end of the table a
hand reaches out and grabs the journal
the pages begin to turn the new models
indicate an anomalous catastrophe is
imminent not even the foundation can
stop it the only way to save the world
is to kill the overseers there are
Whispers from across the table as Calvin
continues the proliferation of anomalies
in the world are the fault of the
overseers theyve been meddling with
reality if business continues as usual
we might not make it out of the 2020s we
need to act now the whispering from The
Shadow Shadows resumes this time with
what seems to be a little more urgency
one of the voices asked the question on
everyone's mind how do you plan to kill
the overseers they have a deal with
death they are Immortal Calvin smiles
and takes out a small vial from his
jacket pocket with this he says there is
a Silence from the Shadows the journal
slides back across the table and comes
to a stop right in front of Calvin a
deep voice from the Shadows says do it
Calvin Lucien gas his team the code name
given to the group is kill Squad he
informs them that they've been cleared
to take out the overseers it will be the
most dangerous Mission they've ever been
on and even if successful they probably
won't make it out alive but the team is
loyal they set out to confront the 13th
overseer this has to be their first stop
because without eliminating
05-13 nothing else will matter it is
this overseer who has a deal with death
a deal that protects all of the
foundation overseers from dying if that
deal can be broken then Calvin Lucien
and his team will have a shot at
eradicating the other overseers if the
deal with death cannot be broken All Is
Lost the team boards a ship at the tip
of South America and sails towards the
Frozen Waters of Antarctica the kill
Squad is made up of Calvin and three
others they sit in the galley preparing
for the mission ahead Anthony Wright is
a battle hardened soldier who sits at
one end of the table his face is covered
with scars no one can remember when he
first joined the Insurgency because it
was so long ago next to him is Olivia
Torres she is an anarchist who was
recruited into the Insurgency after she
was liberated from a foundation site
during a raid Adam Ivanov sits staring
into his computer screen he is testing
different gadgets that might be of use
on the mission he pushes his glasses up
the bridge of his nose and Strikes the
enter key a long line of code begins to
scroll across the screen a siren begins
to to sound informing the crew to make
their way to the main deck when they
surface from the bowels of the ship they
see something in the distance it is a
giant black Tower rising from the depths
of the ocean like an evil Iceberg waves
crash over the side of the railings
drenching the deck and crew with frigid
water Calvin looks at the jagged rocks
along the shore of the tower there is no
way to safely dock there is only one way
onto the island they know what needs to
be done Anthony waits for the next way
wave then opens the throttle to full the
ship is carried towards the island on
the crest of the wave the hole is
impaled and The Rock surrounding the
tower sending everything flying towards
the front of the boat see that wasn't so
bad Calvin says to his team as he
bandages a gash on his hand knowing what
lays ahead Calvin orders his team to
wait on the ship while he makes his own
deal with death he enters the dark
structure and is greeted by a corpse the
corpse speaks to him ejecting dust from
its lungs with every word its breath
smells like decaying flesh death has
inhabited the body of Dr Felix Carter
the 13th overseer Calvin is prepared
though thanks to the notes in the
journal he possesses without hesitating
he takes out a small bottle of liquid
from his pocket and lunges at the corpse
he grabs it by the neck tilts the head
back and pours liquid down what is left
of the throat to Felix Carter the corpse
reanimates into the living doctor Carter
death has been removed from his body by
liquid from the Fountain of Youth that
Calvin had acquired on a previous raid
on a foundation site seeing that Dr
Carter is now alive Calvin takes out his
pistol and shoots the doctor twice
killing him Calvin picks up the body and
throws it into a bottomless pit at the
base of the tower Dr Felix Carter's body
disappears from sight the overseer's
deal with death is now broken they are
vulnerable and can be killed at last
Calvin smiles and begins to turn away
from the pit when he comes face to face
with death she stands with her head
cocked to the side looking at Calvin so
it is you who has broken the overseer's
deal with me Calvin Lucien Calvin takes
a step back why didn't she stop him from
killing Felix Carter something festers
at the heart of the council death says
something that will not die I thought
that perhaps if I had a seat at their
table I could find it make it die but I
couldn't there are things in this world
Beyond even my reach Calvin Lucien with
that parting thought death vanishes the
kill Squad contacts the urgency for an
Evac and then makes their way to Japan
where 05-12 also known as the accountant
has been working out of Tokyo he is so
proficient in mathematics and
probability that he can actually predict
the future everything about the
accountant's life down to the number of
breaths and steps he takes each day is
predetermined based on his own
statistical models this poses a problem
for Calvin and his team if the
accountant can see them coming then how
can they possibly kill him that night
the accountant steps out of his car he
looks to the left and spots Adam he has
already predicted this man has hostile
intentions the accountant walks directly
towards Adam and before he can react
throws the kill Squad member to the
ground then he turns slightly and
adjusts his watch sending a glare
directly into the window where Anthony
has the ACC accountant in his sights of
his sniper rifle Anthony fires but
misses due to being blinded by the glare
the accountant is surprised that he just
barely had time to avoid being shot
normally he would be several steps ahead
of anyone trying to kill him he turns
his head and watches as Olivia helps
Adam up and they run down a nearby alley
the accountant pursues them and Corners
the kill Squad members in the alley he
pulls a gun to shoot Adam but Olivia
tackles Adam behind a dumpster as the
bullet hits the wall directly behind
where Adam was standing the accountant
can't believe that he missed and that he
was almost tricked into being captured
by the Insurgency team he senses
uncertainty in his as salent actions and
runs away unable to predict exactly what
they're planning to do the accountant
climbs the stairs to a Subway Way
Station and Boards the last car of the
train it is empty except for one man
Calvin Lucien the accountant is
dumbfounded how are you here he screams
I should have seen this coming Calvin
stands up he uses his thumb to flip a
coin into the air on the way down he
grabs it and smacks it on the back of
his opposing hand Calvin Smiles the team
has been making their decisions based on
the flip of a coin which introduced
Randomness into their actions that even
this super Advanced mathematician could
not account for tell me where 05-11 is
demands Calvin the accountant pauses
then shakes his head no if he's going to
die either way then why give any
information to the kill Squad Calvin
flips the coin up in the air catches it
and looks at it the coin is face up
Calvin lifts his pistol and shoots the
accountant in the head a few nights
later Olivia stands on a balcony outside
of an Art Exhibit overlooking the city
of Seattle Anthony walks up behind her
and tells her that the foundation is
defeated but Olivia doesn't understand
how we broke the overseer's deal with
death and killed the accountant there's
nothing more to do we can go back to our
normal lives he tells her Olivia is
skeptical though what about the 11th
overseer and his ability to Olivia's
eyes suddenly go wide she pulls out a
knife and stabs it into Anthony's Heart
the world around her begins to distort
and fall apart it was a false reality
created by
05-11 better known as the liar Olivia
wakes up next to Adam in a hotel room
she sits up in a bed and rubs her eyes
what a weird dream she thinks then she
realizes it wasn't a dream she shakes
Adam awake neither of them have any idea
how they ended up here but they know it
must be the doing of the liar they had
planned for this though with Calvin
having created a contingency plan they
pull out a laptop and log in to view the
classified information Calvin left for
them Olivia begins to type but stops
halfway through her password and looks
up from the screen Olivia pulls out the
gun that rests under her pillow and
shoots at him the false reality created
by the liar falls apart around her
Olivia comes out of the previous lie and
is sitting across the table from Calvin
she immediately draws her pistol and
points it at Calvin's head is it really
him or just another one of the Liar's
games Calvin tries to talk Olivia down
and she looks around the room for
inconsistencies that might tip her off
that this is another lie but doesn't
find any Olivia begins to relax she
tells Calvin that the liar is trying to
get something from her maybe the journal
can tell them what he is looking for as
long as she still has it Olivia nods her
head and holds out her wrist where a
subdermal chip with a copy of the
journal on it has been placed Calvin
looks at her wrist the world around them
begins to dissipate as Calvin morphs
into the liar Olivia wakes up in a
hospital where she is hooked up to an IV
sitting across from her is a former
Insurgency agent Named Sam beel he
explains to her that he is the liar he
was forced into becoming a monster by
the foundation they had manipulated him
but now he is tired of running and can't
do it anymore she is free to to go
Olivia hesitantly unhooks herself from
the IV she walks out of the hospital
room and proceeds down a fluorescent lit
hallway as she walks away she hears a
gunshot from the hospital room as
Olivia's in the hospital Calvin and Adam
walk through a dense forest they are
searching for 05-10 the journal
indicates that the 10th overseer's
identity within the foundation is the
archivist in the middle of the clearing
are two saplings standing side by side
the void between the sapling shimmers
Cen walks through the portal and the
space begins to warp and twist around
him his vision finally comes back into
focus and Calvin finds himself in
another world Adam enters the World
Behind Calvin practically knocking him
over as he enters through the portal
this is The Wanderer library but it
doesn't look anything like they expected
instead of rows of books the library is
filled with computer mainframes humming
with the collected knowledge of how to
contain anomalies a critical backup
as the two look intently at the strange
machines a figure in a silver robe
suddenly steps out of the darkness it's
tall and thin and though its hood is
pulled down so they can't see its face
they can see that its hands are covered
in scales that have a slight Emerald
tint it is one of the Librarians Calvin
tells the librarian that they're seeking
the archist but the librarian tells them
that the archist is no longer in the
library she has broken her packed with
the serpent and each fruit from The
Forbidden trees if they want to see her
though the librarian can take them to
her Calvin and Adam follow the librarian
down a long staircase passing by
countless doors filled with books
Scrolls works of art an entire universe
of knowledge eventually they reach the
bottom of the stairs where there stands
a giant set of brass doors Beyond the
Door the librarian explains is the
source of all knowledge before Calvin
and Adam pass through the doors though
Calvin turns to the librarian before we
go in I'd like to make a withdrawal he
says the librarian nods and pulls out a
silver tube out of its robe it hands the
tube to Adam and he looks it over in his
hands he looks up to ask what this is
but the librarian has vanished the door
then opens and the two step through
Calvin and Adam feel as if they walk
through the same kind of portal that
brought them to the library and find
them they have walked into a lush Green
Valley with two trees sitting underneath
one of them is a woman in a white dress
she is reading a book and eating a piece
of fruit are you the archivist Calvin
asks the woman nods yes and that's all
the confirmation Calvin needs he raises
his pistol and fires but the bullet
passes right through the archist as if
she wasn't there do you read the
archivist asked Calvin seemingly not
phased by his attempts to shoot her I
haven't had much time recently Calvin
replied the archivist explains that
she's read every book in the library the
collected knowledge of the universe is
in the books even one on how to allow
bullets to pass through your body she
came here to find the secret to
immortality it's her job to document
everything that happens in the world and
she can't do that if she's dead she
explains that she figured out that the
fruit that the serpent forbade everyone
to eat wasn't actual fruit but the
knowledge contained in the library by
having read every book she has consumed
the fruit she no longer needs the
serpent because she was the serpent the
archist falls to the ground and begins
to wri around contorting her body as it
starts to change she begins to elongate
as her limbs seemingly disappear the
next thing Calvin and Adam know they're
face to face with a giant snake Calvin
Dodges as the serpent lunges at him and
Adam stands in the doorway firing at the
snake with his pistol but just like with
the archists human form the bullets have
no effect the serpent coils around
Calvin and begins to choke the life from
him as Adam can only watch helpless
Calvin cries out with his last breath
the tube Adam open the tube Adam takes
the tube that was given to him by the
librarian and opens the cap a long heavy
spear slides out that looks much too
large to have ever fit inside he drops
the tube to the ground and watches an
amazement as it starts to transform
turning into what looks like a large
Harpoon Gun Adam knows what to do and
places the giant spear into the gun and
points it at the serpent you can't kill
me the giant snake says I've eaten from
the Tree of Life Adam pulls the trigger
and the huge spear flies through the air
striking the serpent in the head Adam
runs to Calvin and helps him to his feet
they turn to look at the snake but
instead of the menacing creature it's
the archist once again again pinned
against the tree she once sat under the
spear sticking out of her skull as the
two stand looking at the archist a tall
hooded humanoid figure steps out from
behind the tree it looks similar to The
Librarian except its robe is a greenish
color and it wears long black gloves the
creature pulls the spear out of the
archist whose body slumps to the ground
and hands the spear to Calvin who are
you Calvin asks but his question is
ignored after a moment the figure
finally speaks that spear you now hold
is called the Spear of the nonbeliever
it is an ancient weapon used to kill
Gods it is odd that someone in this
realm gave you the spear even with it
I'm not sure you will be able to
complete your quest Calvin Lucien but we
shall see there is a sudden flash of
light and Calvin and Adam find
themselves transported back to the
forest they had entered the wanderer's
library from a a week later Calvin and
Anthony Tracked Down 0 5-9 who in the
council is known as The Outsider she
isn't hard to find and it seems as if
she actually wanted to be found they
find her sitting outside of her burntown
family home the journal had listed this
as her address but Calin doubted that
she would be here and most he hoped to
find a clue to her whereabouts but here
she was sitting in the ashes of her home
without turning around the outsider
began speaking the council just used me
you know she says they took away my my
academic career my friends and my life
they made me conduct research for them
that compromised everything I stood for
and now here I am with nothing The
Outsider lets out a sigh she asks Calvin
if he's afraid of death Calvin shakes
his head and responds Now The Outsider
slumps forward and Calin walks around to
face her she is covered in blood her
eyes move to look up at Calvin you're
lying she says as she dies from
self-inflicted wounds Calvin and Anthony
cross 05- 9 off the list and head back
to the car as they walk Anthony says
what's been on everyone's Minds the last
few days the easy part is done we'll
only get harder from here we know 0 5-8
is in his castle I'm sure we'll get in
but I'm not sure if we'll make it out
alive I know replies Calvin but if we're
going to save the world we must
eliminate the rest of the overseers even
if it means sacrificing our own lives
they get in the car and drive off into
the blood red sunset to pick up the rest
of the kill squad team before their next
mission Calvin Lucian leads the kill
squad team through the mud and freezing
rain in front of them looms The Fortress
of Baron Leman hoodley the eighth
overseer the team has already been
through a lot from breaking the overseer
council's deal with death by eliminating
05-13 to using the Spear of the
non-believer to kill the Godlike archist
05-10 the hunting of overseers has taken
a toll on the kill Squad 05-12 almost
killed Adam and Olivia was stuck in what
seemed like an endless mind game with
05-11 the first five overseers were
eliminated but the words that the ninth
overseer spoke to Calvin Lucien before
she died still run through his mind are
you afraid of death now the kill Squad
is about to infiltrate one of the most
heavily guarded facilities in the world
to eliminate the eighth overseer upon
reaching the castle the team is
surprised to find the structure is in
ruin no one is supposed to know the
location of 058 though the Fortress was
supposed to be prac Bally impregnable
they storm the castle of 05- all the
same the journal Calvin possesses that
contains information about the members
of the SCP foundation's powerful 05
Council identifies him as a former
industrialist named Baron Leeman hudley
with his vast wealth hle funded the
foundation at the start and was
considered the unofficial leader of the
council in its early days with immense
control over the actions of the
organization the kill Squad makes their
way through the dimly lit hallway ways
of the castle as they turn the corner
they're surprised to find the charred
remains of Baron Leeman hole's
bodyguards it seems that someone or
something has gotten to hodle before
they could the team makes their way to
the main chamber and breaches the door
laying by a still lit fireplace is 0 5-8
the kill Squad scans the room to make
sure the killer isn't still in there
with them Adam walks over to the body
and examines it he quickly realizes that
hoodley hasn't been murdered at all he
sees that Baron holley's body has been
drastically modified using anomalous
technology the overseer used his
immortality to modify almost every part
of his body to make himself stronger
unfortunately for Baron hoodley when the
overseer's deal with death was broken by
Calvin the modifications to his body
slowly tore him apart his regular body
could no longer support all the
modifications and what once made him
practically Invincible became the very
thing that destroyed him the team leaves
the castle and and Crosses 0 5-8 off
their list on their way out Adam pulls
Calvin aside he has the feeling that
Anthony hasn't been completely honest
with the rest of the team he had the
feeling that Anthony was hiding
something from them Calvin had similar
thoughts recently he pushes Anthony for
more information about his past and
Anthony reveals that he's over 100 years
old the vial of water from the Fountain
of Youth that Calvin has was not the
only one early in his career with the
Insurgency he had confiscated other
miles from a foundation's site his Squad
drank the water and it extended their
lives he asks Calvin on what he plans on
doing with his water from the fountain
I'm going to destroy it Calvin tells him
Anthony agrees with this plan once you
drink from the Fountain of Youth you may
extend your life but a part of you dies
at the same time vibrancy of the senses
disappears leading to a seemingly
shallow life if Anthony could go back
and do it again he never would have
drank the water Calvin receives Intel
from the Insurgency that the seventh
overseer is in a small town in Cambodia
the kill Squad makes their way to the
village and surveys the area hoping to
get a glimpse at the overseer who
codenamed green as the team conducts
reconnaissance Anthony tells them that
he thinks the mission is a setup it is
too remote and there are so many unknown
variables but Calvin is convinced that
this might be their only chance to kill
green since green arrived in the area
there has been non-stop chaos she has
destabilized the local governments and
now the area is in an allout War the
team weaves through narrow passageways
between houses and buildings trying to
make their way to the central compound
where green is located suddenly a mob
starts to form they're getting closer
and closer to the team in a quick
decision to avoid being seen Calvin
orders everyone into a nearby building
before Anthony can follow the mob rounds
the corner they spot Anthony and he's
forced to flee Calvin Olivia and Adam
watch as the mob chases after Anthony
but they have to keep moving Calvin
knows that Anthony can take care of
himself and they are too close to their
goal to stop now Calvin slowly opens the
front door of the house they are hiding
in and peers out the coast looks clear
so he signals Olivia and Adam to follow
him before they can step out into the
street a gas canister enters through a
cracked doorway the room fills with
sleeping gas and the team passes out
when they are awake they are tied up in
a large room room with marble vaated
ceilings 0 5-7 is standing in front of
Calvin she smiles wickedly while holding
a knife she compliments Calvin on what
he and his team have been able to do so
far no one believed they could pull off
even a fraction of what they have but
now she has an offer for Calvin she
points towards Adam and Olivia and tells
Calvin he must choose one of them to die
if he doesn't she'll kill the leader of
the riers and plunge another part of the
country into chaos screw you is Calvin's
response very well utters green have it
your way she assassinates the leader
being held in her compound then turns
back to Calvin she now threatens to
torture his team until Calvin makes a
choice of who to kill green slashes
Adam's cheek with her knife as Calvin
screams for green to leave his team
alone and torture him instead green Just
Smiles I'm going to enjoy killing your
friends while you watch as you have
killed so many of my overseers on the
council she reaches up in the air with
the knife above Adam's head before she
can plunge the knife through a skull a
bullet passes through her hand causing
her to drop the knife Anthony kneels on
a rooftop across the courtyard smoking
sniper rifles still pointed at Green who
runs Calvin uses the drop knife to cut
his ropes and chases after green he
follows her to the roof where he watches
as she boards a helicopter the aircraft
lifts off as Anthony Fires at it from
his original position but does no
serious damage in the plausible below
the mob that has separated the team
earlier becomes restless there is
complete chaos and someone fires a
rocket at the fleeing helicopter the
rocket hits the tail of the aircraft
sending it crashing into the plaza full
of riers below as the crowd flees from
the sea Calvin makes his way towards the
wreckage and reaches it at the same time
Anthony does Calvin looks at him smiles
and thanks him for saving his life
Anthony smiles back but before he can
say anything a gunshot rings out and a
bullet rips through his neck Calvin
turns to see where it came from and is
horrified to see the burning body of 05-
7 her skin has been charred black but in
her burnt hand she holds a gun what's
left of her lips curl back in a Sinister
grin as she fires again and hits Anthony
in the chest he falls to the ground
Kelvin runs to him and pulls out his gun
to shoot 0 5-7 but she is already dead
Calvin holds his dying teammate as blood
pours out of his neck and shut but
Calvin can stop this he pulls out the
vial of water from the fountain no wi is
Anthony I have lived long enough thank
you my friend I will see you in whatever
lies Beyond this life Anthony's chest
Rises then Falls it does not rise again
olivan Adam Round the Corner to see
Calvin holding the lifeless body of
their teammate tears flowing from his
eyes the team holds a small ceremony and
burial for Anthony but are only halfway
through their mission and can't stop now
they fly back to the United States where
an undercover Insurgency agent named
Kowalski informs them that 0 5-6 is
already aware they're after him this
overseer is codenamed the American
because he has the power of the entire
US military at his finger tips the kill
Squad Scouts the base where the American
is located Kowalski warns them of a
crate that was recently brought to the
base from site 19 the Americans showed
great interest in whatever was in the
container the group sets up a camp on a
hill overlooking the base as the sun
slowly Rises the next day the kill Squad
is spotted by a drone and forced to hop
in their Jeep and try to run they make
their way down the hill finding
themselves in the valley below with no
clear exit in front of them lands a
helicopter as Humvees Roar into the
canyon behind them the team is
surrounded a Jeep pulls up and 0 5-6
steps out he introduces himself as Rufus
King member of the overseer Council but
an American citizen first and foremost
all he really wants is to protect the
country he loves thanks to you I've lost
my immortality and can no longer
effectively protect the United States
anymore the American says to Calvin but
I'm willing to make a deal your freedom
for the Spear of the non-believer rumor
has it that you have the spear in your
possession and you used it to kill the
archivist you give me the spear I will
let you go no replies Calvin I will
never give an overseer the means to
cause more destruction the spear stays
with us very well the American says with
a frown then I suppose my only other
option is to take it from you but not
without giving you a fair chance run
Calvin Lucien run as fast as you can I
will be coming for you the American
turns and walks towards the container
from site 19 which is being lowered from
a helicopter hovering above them Calvin
Sprints back to the jeep with the other
members of his team as they drive away
they hear a horrible guttural Screech
from whatever was inside the container
after a few moments the Army begins to
pursue them out in front of the military
force is 0 5-6 writing SCP 682 he is
using a black whip to urge the creature
forward and they're gaining on the kill
Squad fast a row of vehicles pulls up
beside the American and SCP 682 then
something strange happens a man appears
in front of the oncoming forces led by
the American the man's skin bulges and
seems to be moving from within the skin
of the man slows from his body the
infection that is SCP 610 erupts out of
him and onto the soldiers in the nearby
Jeep SCP 610 begins to infect and
consume everyone around it suddenly
there are thousands of instances of SCP
610 coming from the mountain side
flooding into the valley they close in
and around the Army and 0 5-6 the
American begins fighting off the flesh
eating creatures from the back of SCP
682 but he becomes overwhelmed he can no
longer focus on pursuing Calvin and his
team from the back of the Jeep Olivia
pulls out her rifle she aims and fires
the bullet hits the American in the
chest he is flung off the back of SCP
682 and engulfed in a sea of SCP 610
creatures the kill Squad continues to
drive trying to put as much distance
between themselves and the SCP 610
infestation as possible but then Calvin
suddenly Slams on The Brak standing in
front of them is a man in a black suit
and bow tie he introduces himself as
Blackbird the fifth overseer according
to the journal his actual name is
Mortimer Jay Denning Von Kiker he stands
in front of the jeep with a menacing
grin you have been causing a lot of
trouble he says looking at Calvin Olivia
swings her gun around oh please my dear
that won't help you Von cnar says he
pulls out a knife and stabs himself
through the neck he falls to the ground
apparently dead there is a gust of wind
a whiff of ozone and an identical copy
and still very much alive on Kiker lands
next to his own dead body see what I
mean he says Olivia lowers her rifle
come with me I have something to show
you the black bird bir beckons seeing no
other option Calvin Olivia Adam exit the
Jeep and followed the Blackbird as they
walked the world changes around them the
desert mountains Fade Away into
Blackness and find themselves in the
near apocalyptic London oh it's good to
be home the Blackbird says as they
emerge onto a cobblestone street you
cannot stop the overseers plans however
I can give you an alternative let's see
if any of you will take it in front of
each kill Squad member appears adore
they have an uncontrollable urge to open
their respective door and walk through
the Blackbird stands smiling as he
watches Calvin Olivia and Adam enter
each of their portals Adam enters his
door and looks around he is in Portland
his parents walk into the room in this
universe his family has been granted
Asylum Adam never has to interact with
any scps or the foundation he is free to
live a normal life from the kitchen
comes Calvin wearing an apron he is
holding a steaming pot Adam locks eyes
with Calvin who Smiles at him the
Blackbird Whispers into Adam's ear in
this reality both of your parents and
siblings are still alive also the man
you love loves you back you and Calvin
could be married if you stayed here
wouldn't that be nice Olivia enters her
door she is on the deck of a yacht at
the bow sits an easel with art supplies
the man that Olivia once loved walks
across the deck towards her the black
bird Dooms over her in this reality you
didn't accidentally kill him this could
be your happily ever after wouldn't that
be nice Calvin steps through his door
he's in a grassy clearing near a lake
the Blackbird hisses in Calvin's ear I'm
giving you the opportunity to save your
mother this time Calvin you were just a
scared little boy but in this reality
you can be brave you can actually save
your mother from her fate no Calvin
screams this isn't real the Blackbird
cackles Calvin looks away from the lake
and towards the tree line hidden in the
shadows he can just barely make out a
hooded figure Calvin walks towards it
the Blackbird follows he is screaming at
the person in the tree line I was only
trying to help the hooded figure reaches
out and hands Calvin a metal tube he
opens it to find a set of eyeglasses
inside Calvin puts them on and turns to
look at the Blackbird he steps back in
horror the glasses have revealed the
true form of the Blackbird he is a
winged pseudo Aven monstrosity full of
Rage the mysterious hooded figure
directs Calvin to open the tube again
inside is an interdimensional fishing
line made by DR Wonder tainment and a
white whiffle ball bat Calvin grabs the
fishing line and wraps it around 05- 5's
leg the Blackbird flies into the air
trying to get away from Calvin but
Calvin wraps the other end of the
fishing line around his arm the
Blackbird begins to jump from Dimension
to Dimension trying to get rid of Calvin
they appear on the deck of SCP 455 in
sight 19 where SCP 682 walks freely in
the dead world of SCP
2935 every time they stop in a new
dimension Calvin takes the opportunity
to attack the blackbird with the bat and
it seems that he is slowly weakening the
monster they finally land at the bottom
of a deep well foundation containment
site where the dark body that is SCP 001
is contained standing in front of the
containment field is Allison Cho The
Black Queen whose sole mission is to
destroy the foundation you cries the
Blackbird you are the one who's been
helping Lucien The Black Queen nods her
head yes I have been helping Calvin
Lucien to eliminate you and the other
overseers the foundation Must Fall you
are nothing you cannot stop me I am the
black king screams 0 5-5 five Allison
Chow sigh she pushes a button on the
panel next to her shutting down the
array containing the dark body out of
the cloud of dust appears SCP 001 a
massive black creature who seemed to
absorb all light no stop shrieks the
Blackbird SCP 001 does not move but the
room begins to shake the Blackbird
continues to scream as his body folds in
on itself until he is reduced to a
single super repeated point and then
blinks out of existence Allison Chow
then reactivates the containment array
sealing 001 away once again I will
return you to your reality along with
your friends says the black queen but
perhaps our path shall cross again
Calvin Lucien there is a bright flash of
light and Calvin finds himself on a
private jet sitting next to Olivia and
Adam they are all shaken but the
Blackbird is dead 0 5-5 has been
eliminated the three members members of
the team sit silently still pondering
What Might Have Been if they stayed in
the alternate realities suddenly the
phone on the plane begins to ring
breaking the silence Calvin picks it up
on the other line is the fourth overseer
he has contacted Calvin to discuss
surrendering to the Insurgency
unfortunately things do not always go as
planned Calvin Lucien is about to make
the most difficult and dangerous
decision of his life Aaron seagull
better known to Foundation members as
05- one descends into the abyss of a
Deep Well site he exits the elevator and
peers into the optical scanner to unlock
the reinforced door inside the room is
mobile task force tow 5 samsara Aaron
seagull refers to these Immortal cyborg
clones created from the Flesh of a dead
God as his red right hand your mission
is to eliminate the Traer 05- 4 and to
find the insert surgeons who have been
killing the members of the overseer
Council the cyborgs stand at attention
now Aaron seagull screams the soldiers
of the red right hand March out the door
to start their mission Aaron seagull
pauses for a moment and then slams his
fist against the wall in frustration he
has lost nine overseers to Calvin Lucian
and his kill squad team they have been
somehow overcoming the odds each time
and eliminating each overseer they
tracked down it wasn't supposed to end
this way Aaron seagull vows to kill them
all Calvin Lucian meanwhile sits on a
private jet with Adam and Olivia he had
just hung up the phone after a
conversation with 0 5-4 the overseer
known as the Ambassador wants to
surrender to the Insurgency there's a
good chance this is a trap but Calvin
has decided to meet with the Ambassador
all the same Calvin drops off Adam and
Olivia at an Insurgency base they still
haven't fully recovered from the
previous Mission with 0 5-5 known known
as the Blackbird before leaving though
Calvin meets with an Insurgency agent
named Sylvester Sloan who is going to
join him as support Calvin says goodbye
to Adam and Olivia then leaves with
Sloan to meet The Ambassador in South
Africa after landing at Johannesburg
airport Calvin and Sloan disembark and
are led to a conference room where the
Ambassador sits waiting for them Calvin
and Sloan sit across from 0 5-4 to
discuss his surrender the council is in
shambles says the Ambassador and
everything is falling apart I want to
offer my services and information to the
Insurgency in exchange for protection
from
05-19 Calvin agrees to the terms and
prepares for extraction but as they get
up from the table gunshots can be heard
from down the hall the ambassador's eyes
open wide in Terror it's too late he
whispers Calvin and Sloan grab the
Ambassador who is Frozen in fear and
exit the conference room they make their
way towards their plane but the gunshots
are getting closer Calvin looks over
over his shoulder to see Sam sorrow
pursuing them through the terminal
Calvin shoves the Ambassador behind a
table as bullets whiz overhead Calvin
and SLO return fire but their volley
doesn't seem to slow down the Assassins
Calvin and Sloan pull the ambassador to
his feet and they burst through an
emergency exit onto the sunbaked tarmac
where they make a Mad Dash for the plane
from behind them a bullet rips through
the chest of Sloan the red right hand
has caught up but Calvin continues to
drag the Ambassador towards the plane
they are almost there suddenly a
metallic child's Voice blares through
the airport's external speakers the
child's voice says I want Calvin Lucien
alive I have business to settle with him
the red right-and soldiers tackle Calvin
and the ambassador to the ground when
they are just feet away from the plane
kill the traitor the child's voice says
and Calvin can only watch helplessly as
the Ambassador is violently murdered one
of the agents turns towards Calvin and
slams his fist into Cal Calvin's face
causing him to black out Calvin awakes
in a dark room he is unsure how much
time has passed the only light in the
room comes from a screen on the wall in
the middle of the screen is a rotating
red SCP Foundation seal a voice from a
speaker speaks hello Calvin Lucien my
name is the kid I am the third overseer
you have killed all my friends and now I
will kill all of yours the door to the
room opens Calvin leans through the
doorway there is a long dimly lit
hallway the kid orders him to proceed so
they can meet face to face as Calvin
walks the kid's voice Echoes down the
hallway there once was another
the ability of the allseeing eye I now
watch everything all of the time I have
perfect reasoning perfect awareness and
perfect understanding Calvin gets to the
end of the corridor which opens up into
a large chamber tied up in the middle of
the room are Olivia and Adam Calvin runs
to his friends and crouches down next to
them a mechanical suit stands on a
platform looking down at Calvin Alivia
and Adam Calvin realizes the kid must be
contained inside I now sent you all to
death the mechanical suit says as the
red right hand steps out of the shadows
and slowly walks towards the remaining
members of the kill Squad suddenly
there's a flash of light and the black
queen appears stop what are you doing
shrieks the kid the black queen hands
Calvin the interdimensional rod and reel
he used to defeat the Blackbird Calvin
casts the rod from out of the terror in
space comes a massive multi-armed
creature known as madron the red right
hand engages the monster trying to force
it back into its Dimension but the
monster is too powerful he grabs the
cyborg clones and pulls them through the
tear in reality as samsara battles the
madicon Calvin frees Olivia and Adam
they make a run for the door but as they
flee one of the walls opens up to reveal
a turret the gun fires and a bullet hits
Olivia directly in the head killing her
instantly no yells Calvin before Calvin
can push Adam out of the way a second
Bullet From the turret lodges itself in
Adam's back Calvin and Adam slide across
the floor the kid in his mechanical suit
jumps down from the platform above I am
going to kill you now Calvin Lucien he
says in his mechanical voice there is
another flash of light Calvin watches in
front of him as the Spear of the
non-believer manifests itself before his
eyes Kelvin grabs the spear and shoves
it into the kid's machine body it easily
penetrates the armor and pins him to the
wall Calvin walks up to the exoskeleton
and and tears off the outer plating
revealing a tank full of fluid within
which floats a malformed human fetus as
Calvin finally looks upon the kid's True
Form he hears the sound of mocking
mechanical laughter Calvin breaks the
glass and crushes the kid with his bare
hands as Calvin turns from the now
silent robotic body of the kid the room
begins to shake debris raining down from
above Calvin helps Adam up and puts
Olivia's lifeless body across his
shoulders what remains of the kill Squad
makes their way out of the kid's Lair
outside of the foundation site where
they were being held Calvin helps Adam
lie down on the ground before gently
setting Olivia's body next to him Adam
grimaces as blood pours out of the wound
in his back Calvin reaches into his
pocket and pulls out the vial of water
from the Fountain of Youth there are
only a couple of drops left which he
pours into Adam's mouth Adam looks up at
Calvin tears filling his eyes he
whispers I love you you before he passes
out from the pain the wound in his back
begins to heal instantly and Calvin
calls an Insurgency Evac team to come
pick up Adam with Adam safe Calvin picks
up Olivia and walks alone towards a
truck in the lot outside of the
foundation site he needs to finish this
once and for all he will kill the last
two overseers or he will die trying o
5-1 Aaron seagull arrives at where the
Tigris and Euphrates rivers meet the
guard Garden of Eden he is in a frenzy
due to the assassinations of all the
other overseers besides himself and the
Nazarene and nothing will stop him as he
approaches the gate to the Garden of
Eden though he is stopped by the
guardian of the garden a massive
powerful anomalous entity with a flaming
sword but Aaron seagull has no time or
patience for anything to get in his way
even something as powerful as the gate
Guardian the guardian swings his burning
sword at Adam who rolls out of the way
and in a Flash takes out a Scranton
reality anchor he slams The Anchor into
the ground which causes the world to
Shimmer and ripple around him he watches
as the Flames from the gate Guardian
Sword seem to absorb back into its body
before it shrinks down looking to fold
in on itself until all that is left is a
charred skeleton with the guardian
defeated Aaron Sprints into the garden
he searches the garden for 0 5-2 but
can't find her anywhere he finally comes
to the tree of life and that's where he
finds her laying at the base of the tree
in a pool of blood is the Nazarene she
has taken her own life this is her
anomalous power though she has died many
times before yet death always spared her
and brought her back but somehow he
knows this time is final Aaron drops to
his knees and screams and frustration
for all the power Aaron seagull
possesses there's nothing he can do now
he sits next to the nazar's body for
hours hoping that she might wake up or
that he will to find that this was all a
dream after sitting next to her cold
body for some time he notices something
in her Snowy White Hand it's a not in it
the Nazarene explains that she was the
one who gave the vials from the fountain
to Calvin Lucian and that she is the one
who made the spear appear before him
that he used to kill the kid she
explained that while she died many times
in death always brought her back each
time she felt less and less like herself
less and less like Dr Sophia light she
hoped that maybe if things ended up like
this it would give Aaron the chance to
walk away and live the life that they
might have been able to have together
but she knows deep down that Aaron's
fade is to meet Calvin and finish things
once and for all Aaron seagull screams
and rage clutching the node in his hand
he tries to summon death but no one
comes Aaron seagull is alone he stands
up and walks deeper into the garden he
walks until he reaches a spot where even
God's light does not reach in this
desolate land is an impact crater where
Lucifer star of the morning had fallen
in the middle of the crater lies
Lucifer's sword Aaron seagull descends
into the hole and picks up the sword he
turns and exits the Garden of Eden Aaron
seagull has only one mission in life now
two kill Calvin Lucien Calvin reads the
final entry of the journal in it the
author warns that although he hopes the
information contained within the journal
is helpful he hopes the reader does not
try to use it the words written on the
final page are this information will
only lead you to a devastating end
Calvin closes the journal and looks up
at the structure in front of him he has
made it to sight 01 he had left Olivia's
body in a cave nearby promising to her
her that he would make this right he now
walks up to the massive doors and places
his hand on the knotted wood the doors
slowly Creek open Calvin pauses for a
moment and looks behind him at the
Setting Sun he enters sight 01 where he
knows 05- one is where Aaron seagull
Waits inside the main hall Calvin sees a
giant doorway in the shape of the SCP
Foundation seal with artistic depictions
of certain scps that he instinct L knows
are special in some way standing next to
the doorway is a 2 m tall man in what
looks to be a futuristic suit Calvin
approaches and asks who this giant man
is he responds that his name is purpose
the red right hand he is the guardian of
5-1 and None Shall enter the sanctum
until he returns he isn't here asked
Calvin no purpose responds he is and
with that he steps aside and lets Calvin
pass through the doorway the doorway
leads into a large room where screens on
the wall flash to life depicting moments
from Calvin's Journey documenting his
entire Quest had he been in control at
all or was this all a setup to lead him
to this moment as he walks forward he
finally sees him sitting at a table in
the middle of the room is Aaron seagull
Euro 5-1 Calvin asks Aaron the man
responds my name is Aaron
Calvin asks about the location of the
second overseer the Nazarene but 0 5-1
doesn't respond without needing any more
information Calvin pulls out his sidearm
and in a Flash fires off five shots the
bullets stopped in the air inches from
Aaron before dissolving in a flash of
light Calvin should have known it
wouldn't be this easy stand up Aaron
seagull Calvin calls up as he holsters
his gun let's finish it Calvin pulled
the Spear of the non-believer from from
his back but Aaron's only response was
to
laugh you don't even know why you're
here Aaron said Calvin calls back I'm
here to kill you because when I do I
kill the foundation because when you're
gone the universe can finally heal
you're like me Calvin Lucien we are both
men driven by our own convictions
regardless of the outcome it would seem
Fate has brought us together now either
your convictions will be broken or you
will die says Aaron seagull he then
draws Lucifer's flaming sword and lunges
towards Calvin Lucian as the two men
clash with one another their
Supernatural weapons begin to destroy
the room around them Furniture is
shattered video screens are obliterated
and fire spreads across the walls Aaron
catches Calvin off balance and swings
the Flaming sword across Calvin's
stomach Calvin slides back from the
impact hunching over from the pain in
his midsection he brings his head up to
to see Aaron seagull running towards him
with a flaming sword high in the air
Calvin brings up the spear from his
knees he leans back and launches it
towards Aaron seagull the spear enters
the final overseer's chest the force
from the throw pinning him against the
wall Aon seagull drops Lucifer's sword
it shatters as it hits the ground he
clutches the shaft of the spear
protruding from his sternum with both
hands 0 5-1 looks at Calvin
unbelievingly you have no idea idea what
you've done it was never about the
overseers Aaron seagull says spitting
out blood with every word it was
something deeper something worse Calvin
walks slowly towards Aaron seagull he
stops just in front of his final enemy
this is the way it ends Calvin says
Aaron seagull manages to whisper one
final word Sophia before his body
finally goes limp Calvin turns to see
purpose standing behind him he's dead
Calvin says half to purpose and half to
himself I killed him after a moment he
asks purpose what he really wants to
know there's a room in this facility
where someone could unmake the
foundation right take me there without
any hesitation purpose leads Calvin back
to the room with depictions of important
scps there purpose opens the door to an
elevator but stops Calvin before he can
get inside I am Duty bound to tell you
purpose said say that once you step
inside this elevator there is no going
back there is only one decision to be
made and it is not one that can be
unmade I know Calvin responds it's time
before stepping inside the elevator
opens a door to reveal a room filled
with bookcases and a huge window
offering a beautiful view of the sun
setting behind the mountains on the wall
are monitors depicting the ways he had
killed all of the overseers and in the
middle of the room is a large desk with
a computer Calvin sits down at the desk
and the computer comes to life the
computer prompts him to scan his
fingerprint which it accepts he's logged
in the computer screen displays numerous
locations around the planet and he
quickly recognizes that they are all SCP
Foundation science then he sees the
single option the computer is giving him
terminate celvin reaches out with his
finger this is it once he presses this
button the SCP Foundation will be no
more his finger is millimeters from the
button when the phone rings Calin hadn't
even noticed that there was a phone on
the desk Calvin stares at it for a
moment then picks it up hello he says
the voice on the other line responds
hello Calvin Lucien my name is the
administrator I've been following your
work for some time now and I must say I
am impressed I have just been informed
that you have completed your mission
congratulations are in order what the
hell are you talking about Calvin asks
please listen says the voice on the
other line the man you just killed was
once in the same exact position you are
in now granted it was a very long time
ago but Aaron seagull originally was
trying to destroy the foundation that
was until I convinced him otherwise and
now like Aaron seagull you will become
the new head of the foundation like hell
I will yells Calvin I could hang up and
walk away right now and be done with all
this you could continues the
administrator but if no one is in charge
of the SCP Foundation millions of people
will die if not billions and then nobody
would be there to manage what comes
after there is silence from Calvin
that's what I thought says the
administrator I look forward to working
with you Calvin Lucian or should I say
05- one the line goes
dead the Ora Bora cycle one of the
biggest most legendary series of entries
in the history of the SCP Foundation
we've covered the events of this SCP 001
epic in six videos which we definitely
recommend you watch before this one to
avoid your brain exploding from the
sheer scope of it all because that's the
thing about the orborous cycle it's a
story so big sprawling and dense that it
can feel almost like an anomaly itself
whether you're immersed in the possible
origin of the broken God the sentient
black hole that can destroy the whole
universe or Calvin lucian's quest to
assassinate the 05 Council it can
sometimes be difficult to see the forest
from the trees but worry not because
that's exactly why we're here today
we're going to step back and look at
this anomalous Odyssey as a whole and
ask the big question why is it all here
together what makes these four different
story lines the children the broken God
atonement and the way it ends one big
cycle as with anything involving the SCP
Foundation there's always going to be an
element of personal interpretation but
now that we've gone through the whole
cycle we think it's worth adding our two
sents to the proceedings so let's start
broad a question you've probably been
wondering is what do the words or borus
cycle actually mean and what is their
significance to the four stories within
while the spelling differ or borus
refers to the ancient symbol of a snake
or dragon eating its own tail forming a
circle a direct connection to the
concept of Cycles the arbar symbol has
existed in a huge number of cultures
from the ancient Egyptians to the
ancient Greeks to Modern Gnostic
Traditions it's often used in alchemy or
other magical practices and has a
variety of meanings such as eternal life
the endless cycle of death and rebirth
and the cycle of renewal anyone familiar
with the tales within the the orborous
cycle is probably already noticing some
similarities Cycles are a common theme
in all of these Works people endlessly
repeat mistakes threats thought to be
contained or destroyed return and often
times those who go out on a quest to
destroy something end up becoming what
they wish to destroy in the first place
in a cycle there is no true end and no
true beginning everything repeats
endlessly but let's start at the closest
thing to the beginning we have the
children in this Tale the foundation
faces off against a terrifying reality
warping group of interests known as the
kingdom of abidon this nasty Group which
came from the Sahara Desert could
seemingly take anything the foundation
threw at them and were able to straight
up vaporize anyone who got too close if
the kingdom was able to amass enough
power it could spell the end of the
foundation and even the subjugation of
the human race enter 0 5-1 a reoccurring
character in the orboros cycle this
outside the box thinker put all his
chips on the twins of God project
designated SCP 001 like many anomalies
before and after it this project would
Infuse a human being with Godlike Powers
but it was a power so great that it
seemed to kill anyone who attempted to
accept it needless to say this was a
major bummer for 0 5-1 but through
Relentless human experimentation even
sacrificing the population of entire
towns to the project he eventually came
up with a solution a horrifying solution
but a solution nonetheless he found that
a group of nine children with ages
varying from 4 to 11 could act as a
human conduit for 001's power and as a
result it could be a weapon capable of
turning the tide against the kingdom of
abidon during the testing phase though
it seemed like 05- one went a little mad
with power he vaporized an entire church
of the broken God place of worship and
used the power of the children to wipe a
few others off the map at his own
discretion his his abuses of power got
so flagrant that the administrator
himself was called in to get a handle on
the situation and surprise surprise 0
5-1 disintegrated him too before
disappearing himself shortly afterwards
in the end the children were deemed too
dangerous to be practical both because
of their anomalous powers and from the
level of ambient radiation they put out
all nine were locked in radiation proof
boxes and buried in the desert though
they each show signs of life to this day
well this may seem disconnected from the
rest of the series it actually
establishes some of the most important
reoccurring themes and ideas of the
cycle as a whole namely the foundation
messing with reality and Performing
horrific acts to achieve their goals the
corruption of the 05 Council and the
fact that these Grand attempts to change
or save the world often blow up in
everyone's Faces Sometimes literally we
also have the introduction and apparent
death of the mysterious administrator
but trust us all Is Not What It Seems
with this one the ripple effect
beginning here will affect everything
going forward next the broken God this
tells the chaotic story of a magical
Clockwork box which is worshiped by the
church of the broken God as a conduit to
their deity and eventually becomes an
all devouring mechanical Kaiju the Beast
soon dubed SCP 001 devoured and consumed
all the metal around it slowly becoming
larger and more destructive if the
foundation didn't take it out before it
reached critical mass they'd be going
toe-to-toe with a Bonafide God a fight
they really weren't sure they could win
thankfully and with a little anomalous
help from SCP 2399 the foundation was
able to destroy the anomaly they removed
its Clockwork C from the wreckage and
contained the anomalous scrap that once
comprised its destructive body however
the foundation soon realized that you
just can't keep a good god down the
Clockwork heart eventually evaded
Foundation containment while being
shipped to a secondary location and and
instead ended up in a small town here it
began to influence the minds of the
residents into more subservient broken
God cultists intent on building him back
up to his former glory it'd be easy to
Discount the broken God as an outlier
seeing as the foundation came out
looking much better here than they do in
any of the other orboros Tales but when
you look carefully its place in the
overall cycle is clear the entry ends
the way it begins with the heart of the
broken God influencing humans to carry
out its bidding the foundation had to
intervene in between these two instances
but in the end there was no net loss to
the broken God itself in a sense the
foundation is doomed to encounter the
same problems again and again
continually defending the world from the
same anomalous threats and the
foundation needs to succeed every time
to maintain peace and normality a major
anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray in
many ways that is the curse of the SC P
Foundation speaking of major anomalous
threats now it's time for part three of
the or borus cycle atonement once again
we start off with the foundation
meddling with Cosmic scale Powers with
the creation of the area 11 Petri Cal
Fontaine spatial stabilization array try
saying that three times fast that was a
machine so powerful it was capable of
creating a singularity though what it
actually ended up doing was turning Dr
Calvin desmat into an Abomination more
specifically into a kind of immensely
powerful humanoid black hole whose
Powers were only restrained by the very
machine that created him think of him as
kind of a malicious Dr Manhattan from
Watchmen this new entity dubbed SCP 001
presented a grim prophecy and an ominous
offer he told the 05 Council that
anomalies were leaking into their
Universe from other realities and soon
the anomalous threat would destroy them
all his offer was to upon his release
wipe out the rest of the mult Multiverse
entirely leaving only our reality free
from anomalous threats unsurprisingly it
was 05- one that was most interested in
this offer so much so that he held a
vote and murdered everyone who voted
against the decision to release SCP 001
having built his consensus among the
survivors on the council 0 5-1 let SCP
001 out unsurprisingly this turned out
to be a terrible decision as one of his
first acts upon being freed was to kill
the members of the 05 Council that had
just voted to release 001 saying that
they themselves were anomalous and
needed to be purged to atone for their
past sins the only Survivor was a member
of the council who abstained from the
vote who was able to recontain SCP 001
inside the petrica Fontaine array for
now once again the Thematic connections
to the rest of the orboros cycle is
clear we have a world-ending anomaly
held off but only temporarily by buying
time before the cycle inevitably
continues we have the foundation abusing
its power and signing off on the death
of countless people in other dimensions
and of course the 05 Council stepped out
of their bounds and actively warped
reality just like they had with the
children before their chickens truly
come home to roost though in the final
part of the cycle appropriately named
the way it ends this piece Chronicles
the story of Calvin Lucien and the kill
Squad an elite group of four chaos
insurgents Soldiers with one goal
assassinating the entire 05 Council 13
of the most powerful people in the world
why because they've been messing with
reality itself time and time again and
it's getting to the point that their
selfish meddling could finally destroy
everything and given that we've already
seen it happen with the children and the
entity that Dr Calvin desmat became it's
hard to disagree with them what follows
is one of the longest and most
complicated tales in all of the
foundation as the kill Squad
systematically encounters and kills each
insane anomalous member of the 05
Council in order to do this they need to
make deals with death itself fight giant
serpents cross Dimensions deal with SCP
610 and SCP 682 containment breaches and
go toe-to-toe with samsara arguably the
foundation's deadliest mobile task force
a number of other insane things happen
along the way like 0 5-1 murdering the
gate Guardian with the Scranton reality
anchor and the black Queen the most
prominent member of the Serpent's hand
helping our heroes defeat more overseers
in the end Calvin Lucien despite losing
almost everything Reigns victorious in
the final battle using the Spear of the
non-believer a weapon so powerful it can
kill Gods Calvin managed to finally kill
the Top member of the overseers 05- one
with the 05 Council destroyed Calvin set
about completing his final task
destroying the entire SCP Foundation but
that didn't happen instead he was
contacted by a mysterious and immensely
powerful being known as the
administrator who gave him some
frightening news he'd just been hired by
the SCP Foundation to be their new 05-
one this was where our last video on the
orboros series left us what happens next
you may ask how does Calvin respond to
this offer he seemingly can't refuse in
this case it seems that the
administrator of being so completely
tied to the nature of the found ation
itself is SCP 001 and while it seemed
that the overseers were mad with power
they were actually always there to keep
the administrator in check Aaron seagler
the 05- one that Calvin had just killed
was doing the exact same thing Calvin
was doing when he became 05- one trying
to destroy the foundation but the
foundation and the administrator cannot
be beaten they can only be joined and
that's exactly what Calvin did becoming
the the new
05-11 his allies vowed revenge for this
betrayal perhaps suggesting that history
would go on to repeat itself once more
in the future because at the end of the
day that's what the ororo cycle really
is the reoccurring threat and the
changing of the guards that accompanies
it there will always be a foundation
there will always be an administrator
there will always be an 05 counsil
nothing starts nothing ends all that
ever changes are the names and faces
involved whether it's Calvin Lucien or
Aaron seagler the wheel keeps turning
the snake devours its own tail the aorus
cycle is and forever will be Eternal now
go check out our full piece by piece
breakdown on the orboros cycle starting
with SCP 001 the children and then check
out SCP 5000 y the full story
compilation just in case we haven't
blown your mind enough for one day